Hello everyone and we have some unbelievably exciting news for you all. Tom, if anything, you are underselling it because this is truly spectacular. On the 4th and 5th of July this year, we are going to be hosting the inaugural. Rest is History Festival. Out of all places, Hampton Court Palace. And crucially, this is just for the people who mean most to us. That is the members of the Rest is History Club. Tom, am I right?
大家好，我们有一些令人难以置信的激动人心的消息要告诉大家。汤姆，如果你说得太保守了，因为这简直太壮观了。今年7月4日和5日，我们将举办首届“历史就是历史”节（Rest is History Festival）。地点就在汉普顿宫。最重要的是，这仅针对对我们意义最重大的人，也就是“历史就是历史”俱乐部的成员。汤姆，我说得对吗？
You are so right, Dominic. So if you want to access tickets for the festival, then you will need to become a member of the Restless History Club, which is so easy to do. All you have to do is go to therestishistory.com, and it's a matter of seconds. Okay, so remember, by becoming a member of the Restis History Club, you will be able to enter that much prized ballot
你说得太对了，多米尼克。所以，如果你想获得音乐节的门票，你需要成为“历史就是历史”俱乐部的会员，这非常简单。你只需要访问therestishistory.com，几秒钟就能搞定。好了，记住，成为“历史就是历史”俱乐部的会员，你就有资格参加那场备受期待的抽签，
for tickets to this thrilling festival. But of course, on top of that, you'll get all our episodes ad-free. You will get early access to our epic series. You will get weekly bonus episodes. You will get access to our exciting new exclusive mini series. Most of all, you'll get an entree to our much love chat community and many more such exciting benefits. So if you want guaranteed access to two tickets, you can join the very top tier of the club and become an Athelstan.
以获取这场激动人心的音乐节门票。当然，除此之外，你还能免广告收听我们所有的节目。你将获得我们史诗系列节目的抢先收听权。你将获得每周的额外剧集。你将获得我们令人兴奋的全新独家迷你剧的观看权限。最重要的是，你将进入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，并享受更多此类令人兴奋的福利。所以，如果你想确保获得两张门票，你可以加入俱乐部的最高级别，成为一名“埃塞尔斯坦”（Athelstan）。
You will also get the exclusive opportunity. to upgrade to a VIP ticket, which includes a range of special perks, including, and this is so exciting, unlimited food and unlimited drink. So go to the restishtisthistory.com and sign up immediately. It is going to be the most extraordinary weekend. There'll be talks, there will be thrilling special guests, there will be historically themed music, there'll be all kinds of treats, there'll be all kinds of action, and there might even be some battles. But above all, it'll be a time for friendship to get to know your fellow members
你还将获得独家机会升级为VIP门票，其中包括一系列特别礼遇，包括——这太令人兴奋了——无限量的食物和饮料。所以，请访问therestishistory.com并立即注册。这将是一个最非凡的周末。届时会有讲座、激动人心的特邀嘉宾、历史主题音乐、各种各样的款待、各种各样的活动，甚至可能还有一些战斗。但最重要的是，这将是一个友谊的时刻，让你去了解你的会员伙伴，
and to get to know Tom and me in a very, very special place, Hampton Court Palace. And I know that I speak for Dominic as well as for myself when I say, we cannot wait to see you there. Like in the name of God, the merciful, compassionate. We Muslim students, followers of Imam Khomeini,
并在一个非常、非常特别的地方——汉普顿宫——去了解汤姆和我。我知道，当我说我们迫不及待地想在那里见到你们时，我不仅代表我自己，也代表多米尼克。就像以仁慈、怜悯的真主之名，我们穆斯林学生，伊玛目霍梅尼的追随者，
have occupied the espionage embassy of America and protest against the ploys of the imperialists and the Zionists. We announce our protest to the world, a protest against America for granting asylum and employing the criminal Shah while it has its hands in the blood of like tens of thousands of women and men in this country.
已经占领了美国的间谍大使馆，以抗议帝国主义者和犹太复国主义者的阴谋。我们向世界宣布我们的抗议，抗议美国庇护并雇用罪犯沙阿，而美国的手上却沾满了这个国家成千上万妇女和男人的鲜血。
So we protest against America for creating a malignant atmosphere of biased and monopolized propaganda and for supporting and recruiting counter-revolutionary agents against the Islamic Revolution of Iran. And finally, for its undermining and its destructive role in the face of the struggle of the peoples for freedom from the chains of imperialism, wherein thousands of revolutionary and faithful people have been slaughtered. So that, of course, was a student,
因此，我们抗议美国制造了一种充满偏见和垄断宣传的恶劣氛围，并支持和招募反革命分子来对抗伊朗伊斯兰革命。最后，我们抗议美国在各国人民为摆脱帝国主义枷锁而进行的斗争中所扮演的破坏性角色，正是因为这种角色，成千上万的革命者和忠诚的人民被屠杀。所以，那当然是一名学生，
and it was a female student, and she was phoning into a Tehran radio station on the afternoon of Sunday the 4th of November, 1979, and she was speaking on behalf of a radical student group called themselves the Muslim students following the line of the imam. And what had prompted this call was a very dramatic development in the ongoing momentum of the Islamic Revolution in Iran. Because a few hours earlier, several hundred Iranian students had broken into the United States Embassy, Compound, in downtown Tehran. Their plan was, I mean, it's what students do all the time.
而且是一名女学生，她在1979年11月4日星期日下午打进德黑兰的一家广播电台，她代表一个激进的学生团体发言，他们自称为“追随伊玛目路线的穆斯林学生”。促成这次通话的是伊朗伊斯兰革命进程中一个非常戏剧性的发展。因为几个小时前，数百名伊朗学生闯入了位于德黑兰市中心的美国大使馆大院。他们的计划是——我的意思是，这就是学生们经常做的事情。
They wanted to do a brief kind of symbolic occupation, but it very rapidly turned into something much, much more serious with seismic geopolitical implications. Because within a few days, they had taken 66 Americans hostage, including Marine Guards, CIA officers and operatives and US diplomats. And Dominic, this crisis escalated very, very rapidly and would become one of the most dramatic humiliations in the whole of American history. Definitely, yes.
他们想进行一次短暂的象征性占领，但它很快演变成了一件非常、非常严重的事情，并具有地震般的地缘政治影响。因为在几天之内，他们扣押了66名美国人作为人质，包括海军陆战队警卫、中央情报局官员和特工以及美国外交官。多米尼克，这场危机升级得非常、非常快，并将成为美国历史上最戏剧性的羞辱之一。绝对是这样。
So, hello, everybody. What an extraordinary reading that was. At one point, I thought you might be accused of punching down. against female students. And then it occurred to me that your female student voice is actually just a little bit along from your Mick Jagger voice.
那么，大家好。刚才那段朗读真是太非凡了。有一刻，我以为你会因为针对女学生而受到指责。然后我突然想到，你的女学生声音其实和你模仿米克·贾格尔的声音有点像。
Anyway, yes, this is an extraordinary story. It's a defining episode in the Iranian Revolution and it's an absolutely catastrophic moment for Jimmy Carter. Poor old Jimmy Carter, he's been through the ringer in the rest of history.
总之，是的，这是一个非凡的故事。这是伊朗革命中的一个决定性事件，对吉米·卡特来说是一个绝对灾难性的时刻。可怜的吉米·卡特，他在“历史就是历史”节目里可没少受折磨。
I mean, he was humiliated when he appeared in our episode about Love Island. So people may remember he was a contestant on historical Love Island. And who did he end up with? Can't remember.
我的意思是，他在我们关于《恋爱岛》的节目中出场时就受到了羞辱。所以人们可能还记得他是历史版《恋爱岛》的参赛者。他最后和谁在一起了？记不清了。
I don't think it was a good match, was it? No, it wasn't. I think was he dumped by Marcia Williams for Judas Ascariot? Yeah, I think something like that happened. He's had a terrible time because last week he collapsed on a run, watched by you at the time, remember? Yes. He was attacked by a killer rabbit. He was upbraided by us for not pursuing peanut diplomacy with the Ayatollahs.
我觉得那不是一段好姻缘，对吧？不，不是。我想他是被玛西娅·威廉姆斯甩了，然后和犹大·伊斯卡里奥特在一起了？是的，我想大概发生了这样的事。他过得很惨，因为上周他在跑步时晕倒了，当时你还在看，记得吗？是的。他被一只杀手兔袭击了。他因为没有与阿亚图拉们进行“花生外交”而受到我们的责备。
I mean, it's such an open goal. And now he's paying the price for his folly. Because this week we are telling the story of the seizure of the U.S. Embassy, the ordeal of the hostages and Carter's absolutely disastrous attempt to rescue them. And we will be welcoming back in the next episode, an old friend and associate to the rest of his history. Yeah, Ronald Reagan will be returning to the show. Very exciting times.
我的意思是，这简直是一个空门机会。现在他正在为自己的愚蠢付出代价。因为本周我们将讲述美国大使馆被占领、人质的苦难以及卡特试图营救他们的绝对灾难性的尝试。在下一集中，我们将欢迎一位老朋友和“历史就是历史”的伙伴回归。是的，罗纳德·里根将回到节目中。非常令人兴奋的时刻。
So let's remind ourselves where we got to. So there'd be months of street protests, rather like the street protest, Tom, that we are witnessing right now. And I know you're keen, aren't you, to bring out the extraordinary resonances between the late 1970s and the 2020s. Yeah, so we're recording this on the 9th of January and who knows what may have happened
那么让我们回顾一下我们讲到了哪里。当时已经有几个月的街头抗议了，就像汤姆，我们现在正在目睹的街头抗议一样。我知道你很热衷于指出20世纪70年代末和2020年代之间非凡的共鸣，对吧？是的，我们是在1月9日录制这期节目的，谁知道当你听到这期节目时，
by the time you get to listen to this. So after street protest, the last Shah, Mohammed Rizhar Pahlavi, had fled Iran on the 16th of January, 1979. 16 days later, the Ayatala, Ruhola Khomeini, returned this extraordinary moment when he returns to the airport.
已经发生了什么。所以，在街头抗议之后，末代沙阿穆罕默德·礼萨·巴列维于1979年1月16日逃离了伊朗。16天后，阿亚图拉鲁霍拉·霍梅尼回国了，这是他回到机场时非凡的时刻。
And then there's a period of total chaos, street battles and paramilitary violence and whatnot. But by the spring of 1979, it's pretty clear the Ayatollah has the initiative. Parameditaries who associate themselves with him control the streets. There's been a referendum and a massive majority for an Islamic Republic. There are Sharia courts that are trying and executing former Shah loyalists. And Dominic, it's not yet institutionalized, is it? But there is increasing pressure on women to start bailing, covering their hair. going into hijab. Yes. Women's rights and other symbols of westernisation have been put into
然后是一段彻底的混乱时期，街头战斗、准军事暴力等等。但到了1979年春天，很明显阿亚图拉掌握了主动权。与他结盟的准军事人员控制了街道。经过全民公投，伊斯兰共和国以压倒性多数获得通过。有沙里亚法庭在审判和处决前沙阿的效忠者。多米尼克，这还没有制度化，对吧？但女性开始戴面纱、遮住头发、穿上希贾布的压力越来越大。是的。妇女权利和其他西方化的象征已经被置于
reverse, really some of them have. And there's still a power struggle going on. So there is an interim government relatively moderate under this guy Merti Bazagan. So he's a weedy beard and moustache. Yes, he's a sort of intellectual goatee beard and moustache. But power is increasingly concentrated in the hands of people with much more luxuriant beards. Huge be it, who are the Council of the Islamic Revolution, and this is dominated by clerics who associate themselves with Khomeini. What nobody knows at this point is where all this is going. It's a situation in great kind of fluidity in flux. So no one knows really what Khomeini wants. He has gone off to the holy city of Gom, which is where he'd been at the seminary, and he's sort of
倒退状态，确实有些是这样。而且权力斗争仍在继续。所以有一个相对温和的临时政府，领导人是这个叫梅赫迪·巴扎尔甘的人。他留着稀疏的胡子和八字胡。是的，他是一种知识分子式的山羊胡和八字胡。但权力正日益集中在那些留着更浓密胡须的人手中。巨大的胡须，他们是伊斯兰革命委员会的成员，这个委员会由与霍梅尼结盟的教士主导。此时没人知道这一切将走向何方。这是一个处于巨大流动性和变动中的局势。所以没人真正知道霍梅尼想要什么。他去了圣城库姆，那是他以前在神学院待过的地方，他有点
hunkered down there, praying and meditating and whatnot. And whatnot. Yeah, there's a whatnot as well. I think he's probably writing mystical poems, isn't he? Isn't that what he enjoys doing? He would imagine so. Yeah, he's thinking about poetry and that's nice. But what the Islamic revolutionary state under clerical guardianship will mean in practice remains very unclear. Because of this sense of uncertainty, there is a deep fear, even paranoia, among Khomeini's partisans, that the forces of Satanism are going to strike back against their revolution.
躲在那里，祈祷、冥想之类的。之类的。是的，还有一个“之类的”。我想他可能在写神秘的诗，不是吗？那不是他喜欢做的事吗？你会这么想。是的，他在思考诗歌，这很好。但在教士监护下的伊斯兰革命国家在实践中意味着什么，仍然非常不清楚。由于这种不确定感，在霍梅尼的追随者中存在着一种深深的恐惧，甚至是偏执，认为撒旦主义势力将对他们的革命进行反击。
and it reminds me a lot of the French Revolution. So in the French Revolution, 1792, 1793, people were convinced that emigres and foreign agents were plotting against the revolution. And guess what? They were. They were right. I mean, I suppose also, we call it the Islamic Revolution,
这让我想起了很多法国大革命的事情。在法国大革命中，1792年、1793年，人们确信流亡者和外国特工正在密谋反对革命。你猜怎么着？他们确实在密谋。他们是对的。我的意思是，我也认为，我们称之为伊斯兰革命，
but the notion of overthrowing a king because he's a king is pretty alien to Islam. I mean, there's a precedent for this in Islamic history, but there is, of course, in European history. So there is a slight irony there that the point, process of institutionalising a republic is of necessity importing certain Western ideas. I guess it is. But also no one knows that the Republic will actually last, right?
但推翻一个国王因为他是国王，这种观念对伊斯兰教来说是相当陌生的。我的意思是，伊斯兰历史上确实有先例，但欧洲历史上当然也有。所以这里有一点讽刺意味，即制度化一个共和国的过程必然会引入某些西方思想。我想是这样。但也没人知道这个共和国是否真的能持久，对吧？
There's a lot of palavi loyalists out there. The Shah are still out there, as we will discuss. You know, rather like in the French Revolution, people were worried that the king would strike back. Of course. This is what people are thinking right now. What is more, as in the French Revolution, the chaos in the capital has triggered revolts all over the country. So Iran, remember, is not a nation state. Iran is multi-ethnic.
外面有很多巴列维的效忠者。正如我们将要讨论的那样，沙阿仍然在外面。你知道，就像在法国大革命中，人们担心国王会反击一样。当然。这就是人们现在所想的。更重要的是，正如在法国大革命中一样，首都的混乱引发了全国各地的起义。所以伊朗，记住，不是一个民族国家。伊朗是多民族的。
And in, you know, for example, the southwestern province of Kuzestan, there has been a revolt by the Arab population. The revolts all over Iran. And actually, that revolt in Kuzestan is the rebellion that inspires the takeover of the Iranian embassy by separatists in London in 1980. So this is the embassy siege that ended with the SAS storming the building. On top of this, there's a very tense relationship with Iran's neighbor, Iraq, because Saddam Hussein, the Iraqi strong man, has been very alarmed by this talk of exporting the Islamic Revolution. Because, of course, he lives in the country, as we discussed, a majority Shiite population. And he is a Sunni. So Saddam Hussein is thinking, hmm, you know, maybe I should strike first and profit from Iran's. fragmentation, which of course he will do triggering the Iran-Iraq war.
在，你知道，例如，西南部省份胡齐斯坦，阿拉伯人口发生了起义。伊朗各地都有起义。事实上，胡齐斯坦的那场起义正是启发了1980年伦敦伊朗大使馆被分裂分子占领的事件。这就是以英国特种空勤团（SAS）突袭大楼而告终的大使馆围攻事件。除此之外，与伊朗邻国伊拉克的关系也非常紧张，因为伊拉克强人萨达姆·侯赛因对这种输出伊斯兰革命的言论感到非常惊恐。因为，当然，正如我们所讨论的，他居住的国家拥有多数什叶派人口。而他是一个逊尼派。所以萨达姆·侯赛因在想，嗯，你知道，也许我应该先发制人，从伊朗的碎片化中获利，他当然会这样做，从而引发两伊战争。
And that goes well. Yeah, for nobody. And finally, Khomeini and his supporters remember that in 1953, the British and the Americans had carried out a coup against Mohammed Mossadegh. And they're very worried that the Americans might be planning another coup. Well, they are, aren't they? And they are, yes. Was it Zubritsky?
那进展得很顺利。是的，对谁都不好。最后，霍梅尼和他的支持者记得，1953年，英国人和美国人对穆罕默德·摩萨台发动了政变。他们非常担心美国人可能正在策划另一次政变。嗯，他们确实在策划，不是吗？他们确实在策划，是的。是布热津斯基吗？
Zubigny of Brzezinski. He sent orders to the American ambassador. He's constantly ringing him up and saying, get that coup going. Come on, where's the coup? So one of the students, Massimu Ebdekar, we quoted her before, as she said later on, we were sure that foreign elements were actively involved in attempts to weaken and undermine our young republic. So French Revolution, isn't it?
兹比格涅夫·布热津斯基。他向美国大使下达了命令。他不断地打电话给大使说，让政变开始吧。来吧，政变在哪里？所以其中一名学生，马苏梅·埃布特卡尔，我们之前引用过她的话，正如她后来所说，我们确信外国势力积极参与了削弱和破坏我们年轻共和国的企图。所以这就是法国大革命，不是吗？
Yeah, it is very French Revolution. And as in the French Revolution, it's A, it is paranoid, but B, it's also true. They are trying to undermine the revolution. So people like Massamu Ebikar and other students, They come to focus on one place above all, and that's the US Embassy. So this is the twillery of the Iranian Revolution. The den of spies, as they called it, the centre of counter-revolutionary intrigue. So the US Embassy, to give people a sense of the place because it's so important.
是的，这非常像法国大革命。而且正如在法国大革命中一样，A，它是偏执的，但B，它也是事实。他们确实在试图破坏革命。所以像马苏梅·埃布特卡尔和其他学生，他们开始关注一个地方，那就是美国大使馆。这就是伊朗革命的杜伊勒里宫。他们称之为“间谍巢穴”，反革命阴谋的中心。所以美国大使馆，为了让人们对这个地方有个概念，因为它太重要了。
It's a two-story brick building. It was finished in 1951. It's in this kind of wooded compound. Americans used to say it looks just like a high school. And it kind of does when you look at photos of it. It looks like the high school in stranger things or something. Or the Simpsons. or indeed the Simpsons, exactly, or indeed any American TV series.
这是一栋两层楼的砖房。它于1951年完工。它坐落在这个树木繁茂的大院里。美国人过去常说它看起来就像一所高中。当你看到它的照片时，它确实有点像。它看起来像《怪奇物语》里的高中或者什么。或者《辛普森一家》。或者确实是《辛普森一家》，完全正确，或者确实是任何美国电视剧。
So because of the relationship with the Shah, the US diplomatic corps always knew the embassy might be a target. And actually, they were first attacked on Christmas Eve, 1978, before the Shah had even left. There was a crowd outside the compound, and they were repelled by US Marine guards with tear gas and by an Iranian army unit, then loyal to the Shah, which defended the US embassy.
所以由于与沙阿的关系，美国外交使团一直知道大使馆可能是一个目标。事实上，他们第一次受到攻击是在1978年平安夜，当时沙阿甚至还没有离开。大院外有一群人，他们被使用催泪瓦斯的海军陆战队警卫和当时效忠于沙阿的伊朗军队单位击退了，那支部队当时保卫着美国大使馆。
Then after the Shah has gone and the Ayatala has returned, there is a second attack on the 14th of February 1979. So this is in the context of the sort of chaos in the streets, the street battles after Khomeini's return. And this was much more serious. So this time the attack was led by Islamic militants with automatic weapons. At the time, Ambassador William Sullivan, people may remember him, he's a Serbic,
然后在沙阿离开、阿亚图拉回国后，1979年2月14日发生了第二次袭击。所以这是在霍梅尼回国后街头混乱、街头战斗的背景下发生的。这次袭击要严重得多。这次袭击是由携带自动武器的伊斯兰激进分子领导的。当时，大使威廉·沙利文，人们可能还记得他，他是一个尖刻的人，
he has white buffoon hair, he's always arguing with the White House. He handled it really well. He said to the Marines, hold your fire, don't shoot back against these blokes, retreat to the Chancery Building, put down some tear gas, sort of retreat behind this cloud of tear gas.
他留着白色的滑稽头发，总是和白宫争吵。他处理得非常好。他对海军陆战队员说，保持克制，不要向这些家伙开火，撤退到大法官大楼，释放一些催泪瓦斯，在催泪瓦斯的掩护下撤退。
The attackers got through the gates, but Sullivan himself went to meet them, and he kept them talking until intermediaries could arrive sent by Khomeini's Revolutionary Council. And Khomeini's men actually had a massive row with the attacker, said, what are you doing? Why are you here?
袭击者冲过了大门，但沙利文亲自去见他们，他一直和他们交谈，直到霍梅尼革命委员会派出的中间人赶到。霍梅尼的人实际上和袭击者大吵了一架，说，你们在干什么？你们为什么在这里？
No one told you to break him. They cleared the compound, and this will surprise some people. Chomini sent a group of clerics a couple of days later to see Sullivan and to say, we're dreadfully sorry that this happened. If this happens again, you know, you have my personal assurance that I will help you. You know, let me know if this happens again. This is all from Sullivan's memoir, mission to Iran, I think it's called.
没人叫你们闯进来。他们清理了大院，这会让一些人感到惊讶。几天后，霍梅尼派了一群教士去见沙利文，说，我们非常抱歉发生了这种事。如果这种情况再次发生，你知道，你有我的个人保证，我会帮助你。你知道，如果再发生这种情况，请告诉我。这一切都来自沙利文的回忆录，我想书名是《伊朗使命》。
So the obvious question is, once this has happened a couple of times, why do the Americans not close the embassy? I suppose it's so important, isn't it, Iran? I mean, it's the fulcrum of its. position in the Middle East. Of course. You're not going to run away, right? And especially if you've got the Iotler's personal guarantee that you'll be safe. And also they want to keep talking to moderate element. They want to swing the government, you know, away from extremism. They want to keep talking to them. Of course, the moderate elements. The one thing of American diplomats love,
所以显而易见的问题是，既然已经发生过几次这种情况，为什么美国人不关闭大使馆？我想它太重要了，不是吗，伊朗？我的意思是，它是美国在中东地位的支点。当然。你不会逃跑的，对吧？特别是如果你有阿亚图拉的个人保证，你会很安全。而且他们也想继续与温和派对话。他们想让政府摆脱极端主义。他们想继续与他们对话。当然，温和派。美国外交官最喜欢的一件事，
it's a moderate element in an Islamic regime. Well, also, the CIA have listening posts on the border with the Soviet Union, on Iran's northern borders. They don't want to give them up, right? They're really important. Now, That said, the Americans are not complete idiots. So they start to wind things down at the embassy. By the spring of 1979, most American nationals have been flown out of Iran. And from about 1,000 and a half thousand people, there are now fewer than 100 people working at the embassy. So if you go to the compound in the middle of 1979, there's a handful of Marines.
就是伊斯兰政权中的温和派。嗯，还有，中央情报局在与苏联接壤的伊朗北部边境有监听站。他们不想放弃这些，对吧？它们真的很重要。现在，话虽如此，美国人并不是完全的白痴。所以他们开始缩减大使馆的规模。到1979年春天，大多数美国国民已经被空运出伊朗。从大约1500人减少到大使馆现在只有不到100人工作。所以如果你在1979年中期去那个大院，只有少数海军陆战队员。
I mean, we're talking about a dozen, maybe, maybe between a dozen and 20 Marines. I mean, that's a hard posting, isn't it? Yeah, you don't really fancy that. There are about 80 local sort of armed men who have been sent by Iran's provisional government. But these blocs just spend a lot of time drinking and squabbling around themselves. So they're clearly not going to be much use in a fight. However, after February 1979, all the militant factions on the streets, they're more worried about fighting each other than they are fighting the Americans.
我的意思是，我们说的是十几个人，也许在十几到20名海军陆战队员之间。我的意思是，那是一个艰苦的岗位，不是吗？是的，你真的不会喜欢那样。大约有80名当地武装人员是由伊朗临时政府派来的。但这些家伙花了很多时间喝酒和互相争吵。所以很明显，他们在战斗中不会有什么用处。然而，1979年2月之后，街头所有的激进派别，他们更担心互相争斗，而不是与美国人作战。
So the Americans are kind of left alone. So a couple of months later, Sullivan has finally recalled to Washington. As we talked about before, Carter has been itching to sack him for months because he thinks he's insubordinate. The State Department do not rush to replace him. They say, look, the situation in Iran is so chaotic. We don't even know, you know, who's in charge. So we don't really know who we should send. We'll get this bloke's deputy who's called Bruce Lengen.
所以美国人被留在了那里。几个月后，沙利文终于被召回华盛顿。正如我们之前讨论过的，卡特几个月来一直急于解雇他，因为他认为他抗命。国务院并不急于替换他。他们说，看，伊朗的局势太混乱了。我们甚至不知道，你知道，谁在负责。所以我们真的不知道该派谁去。我们会让这个家伙的副手，叫布鲁斯·兰根。
He can stay on as the caretaker kind of head of mission until we send out a proper. ambassador later on. Dominic, can I just ask, if they had sent out an ambassador, would that have been an indication to the new Iranian regime that the United States recognized it as the legitimate government? Yes, undoubtedly it would. So that would actually maybe have made a difference, do you think? But in much better.
他可以留下来担任看守性质的使团团长，直到我们以后派出一名正式大使。多米尼克，我能问一下吗，如果他们派出一名大使，那是否会向新的伊朗政权表明美国承认它是合法政府？是的，毫无疑问会。所以你认为那实际上可能会有所不同吗？但情况会好得多。
So a lot of people, some people at least in the State Department, certainly in the US embassy, including Bruce Langen himself, thought, you should send another ambassador because that will send a signal to the Iranian regime. We accept you. We will work with you. We're going to find a way through this. But actually not sending an ambassador at all is a really bad sign. It's a snub.
所以很多人，至少国务院里的一些人，当然还有美国大使馆里的人，包括布鲁斯·兰根本人，都认为，你应该派另一位大使，因为那会向伊朗政权发出一个信号。我们接受你们。我们将与你们合作。我们将找到解决办法。但实际上根本不派大使是一个非常糟糕的信号。这是一种冷落。
Yeah, it's seen as a bit of a snub. Sullivan gets back to Washington. The first thing he does when he gets back to Washington, he says to Cyrus Vance, who is the patrician kind of Ivy League, boarding school educated, secretary of state. Sullivan says to Cyrus Vance, I'd like to see you because I'm actually really worried about our embassy.
是的，这被视为一种冷落。沙利文回到华盛顿。他回到华盛顿后做的第一件事就是对赛勒斯·万斯说，万斯是一位贵族式的、常春藤盟校毕业的、寄宿学校教育出来的国务卿。沙利文对赛勒斯·万斯说，我想见你，因为我真的很担心我们的大使馆。
He says, there is one thing that you could do that would be bound to provoke an attack. And that would be if you ever allowed the Shah of Iran into the United States. So that's his message. Whatever you do, don't allow the Shah of Iran into the United States. Whatever you do, whatever you do, do not do that. So let's get on to the Shah. The Shah, remember, left in January,
他说，有一件事你做了肯定会引发攻击。那就是如果你允许伊朗沙阿进入美国。所以这就是他的信息。无论你做什么，都不要允许伊朗沙阿进入美国。无论你做什么，无论你做什么，都不要那样做。那么让我们谈谈沙阿。沙阿，记住，在一月份离开了，
and the original plan was to him to go to this estate in Palm Springs that has been visited by Tom Holland, Walter Annenberg's estate. But the Shah has not done that. he has hung around and dalled in North Africa with his pal, President Sadat in Aswan in Egypt, and then he's gone to see another mate of his King Hassan of Morocco in Marrakesh. The Shah is now a very sickly, gaunt and miserable figure.
最初的计划是让他去棕榈泉的一处庄园，汤姆·霍兰德曾参观过那里，那是沃尔特·安纳伯格的庄园。但沙阿没有那样做。他在北非徘徊，和他的好朋友埃及总统萨达特在阿斯旺待了一段时间，然后又去见了他在摩洛哥的另一个朋友哈桑国王。沙阿现在是一个非常虚弱、憔悴和痛苦的人。
He has seen the footage of Khomeini's return, and he was really shocked by it. He's gutted about what's happened to Iran. He can't believe it. Of course, he was so out of touch. And he's really disappointed. Now, meanwhile, in Morocco, because, of course, that the Islamic revolution
他看到了霍梅尼回国的录像，他对此感到非常震惊。他对伊朗发生的事情感到非常难过。他简直不敢相信。当然，他太脱离现实了。他非常失望。现在，与此同时，在摩洛哥，因为，当然，伊斯兰革命
has caught the world's imagination. And because the Ayatollahs have made it very clear they'd like to export the ideals of their revolution, King Hassan and Morocco thinks, I don't know that having the Shah here is a very good idea. I mean, there are Islamist groups in Morocco. You know, I don't want them all kicking off because the Shah's here.
已经抓住了世界的想象力。而且因为阿亚图拉们已经非常明确地表示他们想输出他们的革命理想，摩洛哥的哈桑国王认为，我不认为让沙阿待在这里是个好主意。我的意思是，摩洛哥有伊斯兰组织。你知道，我不想因为沙阿在这里而让他们闹事。
So by, after a few weeks, he says to the Shah, I'd really like it if you moved on now. You know, you've kind of outstayed you're welcome. Now, the Shah at this point, this would be the point for him to go to California. However, the Americans have now slightly changed their mind. First of all, there were reports that the Revolutionary Committees in Iran have started arresting foreigners. But also, the National Security Council says to Carter, if we admit the Shah, it would mean, and I quote, mass arrests of Americans in Tehran
所以几周后，他对沙阿说，如果你现在离开，我会很高兴。你知道，你已经待得太久了，不受欢迎了。现在，沙阿此时，这本该是他去加利福尼亚的时候。然而，美国人现在稍微改变了主意。首先，有报道称伊朗的革命委员会已经开始逮捕外国人。但国家安全委员会也对卡特说，如果我们接纳沙阿，这意味着，我引用一下，“在德黑兰大规模逮捕美国人”，
and almost certainly another attack on the embassy. Now, Jimmy Carter, people may recall, is an evangelical. local born again Christian. So you would think he is a kindly man, a man of his word, who would want to honour his promise to the Shah, wouldn't you, Tom? Well, and also, he's gone over to Tehran and toasted the Shah and said how he's his best mate and how he loves him. Yeah, correct.
而且几乎肯定会再次攻击大使馆。现在，吉米·卡特，人们可能还记得，是一位福音派的、重生的基督徒。所以你会认为他是一个善良的人，一个信守诺言的人，一个会想要兑现他对沙阿承诺的人，不是吗，汤姆？嗯，而且，他去过德黑兰，为沙阿祝酒，说他是他最好的朋友，说他有多爱他。是的，没错。
Very publicly. Yes. But do you know what? Jimmy Carter now shows perhaps less Christian side to his character. when they meet in Washington, he says, I think we should forget about the Shah, let's cut him loose, let him twist in the wind. And Brzezinski, who's the hard man, he's really shocked by this. And he says, I think it would be repugnant to cancel our invitation.
非常公开地。是的。但你知道吗？吉米·卡特现在表现出的性格中，基督徒的一面可能少了些。当他们在华盛顿会面时，他说，我认为我们应该忘记沙阿，让我们放手吧，让他自生自灭。而布热津斯基，那个强硬派，对此感到非常震惊。他说，我认为取消我们的邀请是令人反感的。
It would violate our loyalty to our friend. And Carter says, very curtly, I don't want the Shah playing tennis in the United States while Americans in Tehran are kidnapped or killed. Well, it would be very easy for Carter to stop the Shah playing tennis, wouldn't it? Yes. Doesn't put him on the booking list for the White House. Right.
这会违背我们对朋友的忠诚。卡特非常生硬地说，我不希望沙阿在美国打网球，而美国人在德黑兰被绑架或杀害。嗯，卡特要阻止沙阿打网球会很容易，不是吗？是的。不把他列入白宫的预订名单。对。
Yeah. If there's anyone, it's funny. It's so revealing that Jimmy Carter reaches for that image. Right. So anyway, the Shah's now in a mess. Jimmy Carter doesn't want him. So where can he go? Now remember, he has a house in our own beloved country.
是的。如果有人，这很有趣。吉米·卡特想到那个形象真是太能说明问题了。对。所以无论如何，沙阿现在陷入了困境。吉米·卡特不想要他。那么他能去哪里呢？现在记住，他在我们自己心爱的国家有一所房子。
But the weather's terrible. But he said the weather was terrible. Now he gets that idea back. And Jim Callahan, still prime minister, says, no, you're not coming. And then there's an election in Britain. Britain. And Margaret Thatcher, big fan of the Shah, she also says no. I mean, she's the Iron Lady. She's not going to be swayed by obligations to a sick king, is she? Well, do you know what? She actually did. She actually felt really bad about it. But she was told,
但天气太糟糕了。但他说是天气太糟糕了。现在他又有了那个想法。吉姆·卡拉汉，仍然是首相，说，不，你不能来。然后英国举行了选举。英国。玛格丽特·撒切尔，沙阿的忠实粉丝，她也说了不。我的意思是，她是铁娘子。她不会被对一个生病的国王的义务所左右，是吗？嗯，你知道吗？她确实。她实际上对此感到非常糟糕。但有人告诉她，
you know, security on the Shah's estate, which is just outside London, will be a nightmare. Like, we're not convinced. It'll be very difficult to protect this country estate from attackers, but also we will put our own Britain's embassy into Tehran at risk. And they're right. Because actually, I mean, we know that American diplomats are going to be taken hostage. British diplomats are not. And in a sense, bearing in mind the notoriety of Britain in the Iranian demonology, I mean, that is a dog that doesn't bark in the night, isn't it? It is, although there are a massive protest outside the British embassy, but it's not invaded. And they changed the street name, don't they, from Winston Churchill Avenue to
你知道，沙阿庄园的安保工作，就在伦敦郊外，将是一场噩梦。就像，我们不相信。保护这个乡村庄园免受袭击者伤害将非常困难，而且我们还会将英国驻德黑兰大使馆置于危险之中。他们是对的。因为实际上，我的意思是，我们知道美国外交官将被扣为人质。英国外交官不会。而且在某种意义上，考虑到英国在伊朗妖魔化叙事中的臭名昭著，我的意思是，那是一条在夜里不叫的狗，不是吗？确实是，尽管英国大使馆外有大规模抗议，但它没有被入侵。他们改了街道名称，不是吗，从温斯顿·丘吉尔大道改为
Bobby Sands Avenue. Bobby Sands is an IRA hunger striker. Exactly, they do. So the Shah can't go to Britain. He goes off to the Bahamas in the end, and he gets a house on the beach, and he spends his time praying and reading the newspapers, and he rings up foreign diplomats to reminisce about the good old days,
鲍比·桑兹大道。鲍比·桑兹是爱尔兰共和军的绝食抗议者。没错，他们确实改了。所以沙阿不能去英国。最后他去了巴哈马，他在海边买了一所房子，他花时间祈祷和看报纸，他打电话给外国外交官回忆过去的美好时光，
about food from Maxims of Paris and Don Perignon, Champagne and stuff. Great days. And then after that, he goes to Kenavaka in Mexico, and both of these boltholes have been arranged by two American pals of his. So specifically, his great chum, Henry Kissinger, and Kissinger's mate, David Rockefeller of oil family fame, who is the president of the Chase Manhattan Bank. So useful friends.
关于巴黎马克西姆餐厅的食物和唐·佩里农香槟之类的东西。美好的日子。在那之后，他去了墨西哥的库埃纳瓦卡，这两个避难所都是由他的两个美国朋友安排的。具体来说，他的好朋友亨利·基辛格，以及基辛格的朋友，石油家族出身的大卫·洛克菲勒，他是大通曼哈顿银行的总裁。所以是有用的朋友。
Yeah, good contacts. And Kissinger and Rockefeller take it upon themselves to be the Shah's great champions. And they think it's terrible that the United States has abandoned him. And all through 1979, Kissinger and Rockefeller are pestering the Carter administration, allow in the Shah. You're letting America down. This is really poor. Come on. And does Carter respond to this in a tone of Christian obligation? Carter, Tabby, get your bleeping machine ready. Carter says, and I quote, F*** the Shah. I'm not going to welcome him when he has other places where he'll be safe.
是的，好人脉。基辛格和洛克菲勒自认为是沙阿的伟大捍卫者。他们认为美国抛弃他真是太糟糕了。整个1979年，基辛格和洛克菲勒都在纠缠卡特政府，允许沙阿入境。你们让美国失望了。这真的很糟糕。来吧。卡特是以基督徒义务的口吻回应的吗？卡特，塔比，准备好你的消音器。卡特说，我引用一下，“去他的沙阿。当他有其他安全的地方时，我不会欢迎他。”
This is not what Jimmy Carter says when he's teaching a Sunday school in Plains, Georgia, surely. Anyway, the decisive factor is the Shah's health. So basically, his doctors have been visiting him, is French doctors and they can see that his cancer is spreading. He's losing weight. He looks terrible. He's turned yellow with jaundice, all of this. And eventually, David Rockefeller sends his own medical team to Mexico to inspect the Shah, and they go back to Washington and they report to the administration.
这肯定不是吉米·卡特在佐治亚州平原市教主日学时说的话。无论如何，决定性因素是沙阿的健康状况。所以基本上，他的医生一直在看他，他的法国医生能看出他的癌症正在扩散。他正在消瘦。他看起来糟透了。他因为黄疸变得面色蜡黄，所有这些。最终，大卫·洛克菲勒派他自己的医疗团队去墨西哥检查沙阿，他们回到华盛顿并向政府报告。
And in October, 1979, so the 19th of October, there's a meeting at the White House to discuss this. And Carter's aide say to him, I think you should let him in. He's, you know, he's dying. You should definitely let him in. Cyrus Vance, the Secretary of State, says, common decency and humanity demand that we allow the Shah to have treatment in New York. He was our ally.
1979年10月，也就是10月19日，白宫召开了一次会议讨论此事。卡特的助手对他说，我认为你应该让他进来。他，你知道，他快死了。你绝对应该让他进来。国务卿赛勒斯·万斯说，基本的体面和人道要求我们允许沙阿在纽约接受治疗。他是我们的盟友。
He was our man. We can't abandon him now. Carter's chief of staff, Hamilton Jordan, a Georgian like Carter, he points out to the Carter. He says, if the Shah dies in Mexico, Henry Kissinger will go around the world saying, first you caused his downfall and now you've killed him. That's a bit harsh.
他是我们的人。我们现在不能抛弃他。卡特的幕僚长汉密尔顿·乔丹，和卡特一样是佐治亚州人，他向卡特指出。他说，如果沙阿死在墨西哥，亨利·基辛格会满世界说，首先是你导致了他的垮台，现在又是你杀了他。这有点刻薄。
It's the cancer that kills him, surely. Yeah, but that is what Henry Kucenthal would have said. Yeah, okay. So, you know, Hamilton-D Jordan is right. And Carter eventually gives in, but at the end of the meeting, Carter, and we've painted Carter as in some ways, you know, we've perhaps been a bit unfair to Jimmy Carter in some ways. Here, Jimmy Carter shows his shrewdness.
是癌症杀了他，肯定是的。是的，但那正是亨利·基辛格会说的话。是的，好吧。所以，你知道，汉密尔顿·乔丹是对的。卡特最终屈服了，但在会议结束时，卡特——我们把卡特描绘成在某些方面，你知道，我们可能在某些方面对吉米·卡特有点不公平。在这里，吉米·卡特展示了他的精明。
Because Jimmy Carter says, at the end of the meeting, does somebody have an answer as to what we would do if the diplomats in our embassy are taken hostage? And there's a long silence and nobody says anything. And Carter says, I gather not. that day we will all sit here with long-drawn white faces and we will realize that we have been had. So if he's alert to that, why doesn't he withdraw the diplomats before allowing the Shaheen? That's a good question.
因为吉米·卡特在会议结束时说，有人有答案吗，如果我们大使馆的外交官被扣为人质，我们该怎么办？现场一片寂静，没人说话。卡特说，我想没有。那天我们将坐在这里，面色苍白，我们会意识到我们被耍了。所以如果他对此保持警惕，为什么他不允许沙阿入境前撤走外交官？这是一个好问题。
Where they don't want to withdraw their diplomats, they think it's so important to have diplomatic representation and keep talking to these fabled moderate elements, I think. If Carter ran away from Iran, he would be accused of completely losing Iran, I think. So he doesn't want to do that. Yeah, invidious situation. Anyway, he doesn't handle it well, as we will see. So three days later, the 22nd of October, the Shah and Empress Farah arrive in New York,
他们不想撤走外交官，我认为他们认为保持外交代表并继续与这些传说中的温和派对话非常重要。如果卡特从伊朗逃跑，我想他会被指责彻底失去了伊朗。所以他不想那样做。是的，令人反感的处境。无论如何，他处理得不好，正如我们将要看到的。所以三天后，10月22日，沙阿和法拉赫皇后抵达纽约，
and they are rushed straight to the Cornell Medical Center so that he can have emergency surgery. There's no attempt, really. Everyone knows they can't keep this a secret. So even as the doctors are operating on the Shah, there are crowds outside the building chanting against him. And are these Iranian? Iranian students.
他们被直接送往康奈尔医疗中心，以便他能进行紧急手术。真的没有尝试。每个人都知道他们无法保守这个秘密。所以即使医生在给沙阿做手术时，大楼外也有人群在抗议他。他们是伊朗人吗？伊朗学生。
Iranian students. So there were tens of thousands. of Iranian students at American universities. They tend to be anti-Shah, and by this point, when they demonstrate against the Shah or whatever, they often get attacked by Americans or there's scuffles on campuses and things like this, and which will worsen, of course, once the Hostas crisis begins.
伊朗学生。所以有成千上万的伊朗学生在美国大学。他们倾向于反沙阿，到这个时候，当他们抗议沙阿或什么的时候，他们经常受到美国人的攻击，或者校园里发生冲突之类的事情，当然，一旦人质危机开始，这种情况会恶化。
But there are also lots of pro-Shaer Iranians in America. There are the exiles. So increasing the exile groups who've arrived since 1978, settled in places like Florida and California, still exile communities of Iranians in America today. So in Tehran, when the U.S. embassy staff hear the Shah has arrived in New York, oh God, they're not happy. So Bruce Lengen, who is the acting ambassador, had already said to Washington,
但美国也有很多亲沙阿的伊朗人。有流亡者。所以越来越多的流亡团体自1978年以来抵达，定居在佛罗里达和加利福尼亚等地，今天美国仍然有伊朗流亡社区。所以当德黑兰的美国大使馆工作人员听说沙阿抵达纽约时，天哪，他们不高兴。所以布鲁斯·兰根，代理大使，已经对华盛顿说，
please do not do this. Do not do this. And if you are going to do it, clear it with the Iranian provisional government beforehand. Like, explain to them what you're doing. You know, try to smooth the ground. Please send a new ambassador to show that you accept the new regime. And please do something to arrange proper security for Americans in Tehran. And as throughout this story, too many people in Washington just don't listen to the signals they're getting from their embassy.
请不要这样做。不要这样做。如果你一定要这样做，请事先与伊朗临时政府沟通。就像，向他们解释你在做什么。你知道，试着平息局势。请派一位新大使来表明你们接受新政权。请做点什么来为德黑兰的美国人安排适当的安保。正如在这个故事中一样，华盛顿有太多人只是不听他们从大使馆得到的信息。
But in the first few days, Lengen thinks, you know what, we might just get away with this? There is no attack on the embassy. There are marches. But by Iranian standards, the streets feel reasonably calm. So maybe things are going to be all right. what he doesn't know is that at Tehran's University of Technology there are students who have been plotting for weeks to attack the embassy Now there are different groups of students who kind of claim credit for this
但在最初的几天里，兰根想，你知道吗，我们也许能侥幸逃脱？大使馆没有受到攻击。有游行。但按照伊朗的标准，街道感觉相当平静。所以也许事情会好起来的。他不知道的是，在德黑兰理工大学，有一些学生已经策划了几个星期要攻击大使馆。现在有不同的学生团体声称对此负责。
The name that comes up most often is a guy called Ibrahim Ashgazada Who later on actually ended up being a reformist Iranian politician And was actually arrested in the 2000s Oh, so a moderate element Moderate element but not in 1979 He was an engineering student He was absolutely typical of the students who were We're very excited about Khomeini's return.
最常出现的名字是一个叫易卜拉欣·阿斯加扎德的人，他后来实际上成为了一名伊朗改革派政治家。而且在2000年代实际上被捕了。哦，所以是一个温和派。温和派，但在1979年不是。他是一名工程系学生。他非常典型，是那些对霍梅尼回国感到非常兴奋的学生之一。
See it as a chance for a new start, banishing the corruption and the frustrations of the 70s. And he meets up with some friends of his cafe in Tehran one day in the autumn. And they say, we would love to kind of demonstrate our, you know, it's classic student stuff. Let's make a stand, you know, let our voices be heard, all of this kind of thing. Strike at the imperialists. Strike at the imperialists. Why don't we break into the U.S. embassy and from there, proclaim our message to the world? Brilliant idea. They meet up with students from other Terran colleges and they form this group
视其为重新开始的机会，消除70年代的腐败和挫折感。秋天的一天，他在德黑兰的一家咖啡馆遇到了他的朋友。他们说，我们很想展示我们的，你知道，这是典型的学生行为。让我们表明立场，你知道，让我们的声音被听到，所有这些事情。打击帝国主义者。打击帝国主义者。为什么我们不闯入美国大使馆，从那里向世界宣告我们的信息？好主意。他们与其他德黑兰学院的学生会面，组成了这个团体，
with the catchy name Muslim student followers of the Imam's line. Love it. And their plan is they will occupy the embassy for a few hours, maybe a few days, and they will broadcast the message that you read out. We don't like the Shah, we don't like America, we don't like imperialism, you know, Hazar, Hazar, end of story. So it's a sit-in in exactly the way that sit-ins from 1968 onwards have operated in the West and presumably inspired by them. Yes, that's the funny thing, isn't it about the Iranian Revolution? That in some ways, you know, it was often described in the West as backward looking, as medieval, all this kind of thing.
名字叫“追随伊玛目路线的穆斯林学生”。喜欢这个名字。他们的计划是，他们将占领大使馆几个小时，也许几天，他们将广播你读出的那条信息。我们不喜欢沙阿，我们不喜欢美国，我们不喜欢帝国主义，你知道，哈扎尔，哈扎尔，故事结束。所以这是一种静坐，就像1968年以来西方进行的静坐一样，大概是受了它们的启发。是的，这就是伊朗革命有趣的地方，不是吗？在某些方面，你知道，它在西方经常被描述为倒退的、中世纪的，所有这些东西。
And yet it's very modern. And it's informed both by, you know, Shia tradition and also by the Ayatollah's radical vision, but also there's hints of the 1960s and 1968 in there too. Yeah, and that's what people on the left in the West, who are enthusiastic initially, for the Iranian Revolution are picking up on. That's what they liked, exactly. So now we come to the fateful day, Sunday the 4th of November, 1979. It is exactly one year to go until the US presidential election.
然而它非常现代。它既受到什叶派传统的影响，也受到阿亚图拉激进愿景的影响，但其中也隐约有着20世纪60年代和1968年的影子。是的，这正是西方左翼人士最初对伊朗革命充满热情的原因。这正是他们所喜欢的，没错。现在我们来到了决定性的一天，1979年11月4日，星期日。距离美国总统大选正好还有一年。
I mean, you could not make this up. So 365 days' time, Jimmy Carter will face the American voters. And about dawn, 300 students gathered near the embassy. And at least one of the female students, they're wearing these black... Chadors. Yeah, Chadors, black robes. and they have bolt cutters hidden under their chadors. And they're brought enough food for three days.
我的意思是，你简直无法编造出这样的情节。所以，在365天后，吉米·卡特将面对美国选民。大约在黎明时分，300名学生聚集在使馆附近。至少其中一名女学生，她们穿着黑色的……长袍。是的，长袍，黑色长袍。她们的长袍下藏着断线钳。她们还带了足够吃三天的食物。
That's as long as they think the occupation will plausibly last at the outside. They go through the streets towards the embassy. Remember that Tehran, there are always street protests and stuff, so people don't think anything of it. And inside the embassy, nobody really has any idea what's happening. There's a brilliant book on this by an American writer called Mark Bowden called guests of the Ayatollah, all about the siege and the hostage experience, which I heartily recommend to the listeners. And one of the people he talks about in this book is the press attache,
这是她们认为占领行动在最长情况下可能持续的时间。她们穿过街道走向大使馆。记住，在德黑兰，街头抗议之类的活动总是不断，所以人们对此并不在意。而在大使馆内，没有人真正知道发生了什么。美国作家马克·鲍登写过一本关于此事的精彩著作，名为《阿亚图拉的客人》，全书讲述了围困和人质经历，我衷心向听众推荐。他在书中提到的其中一个人是新闻专员，
who was Barry Rosen, who was a big sort of Iranophile. He'd been a peace corps volunteer in Iran. He spoke farcee, all of this. He's in his office. It's nine o'clock. He's typing a report, and he hears shouting at the window. He goes to the window with his secretary. There's this huge crowd. Men with a lot of stubble shouting, death to Jimmy Carter, death to America, women in their chadours, fists pumping, hurrah for the Ayatollah, all this kind of thing. Standard stuff. And he watches it for a little while.
也就是巴里·罗森，他是一个大大的“伊朗迷”。他曾是伊朗的和平队志愿者。他会说波斯语，诸如此类。他当时在办公室。时间是九点。他正在打一份报告，突然听到窗外有喊叫声。他和秘书走到窗前。外面是一大群人。留着胡茬的男人们高喊着“打倒吉米·卡特，打倒美国”，穿着长袍的女人们挥舞着拳头，高呼“阿亚图拉万岁”，诸如此类。标准流程。他看了一会儿。
And then to his horror, he sees they're starting to climb the gates. And I guess if you're an American diplomat in the 70s, seeing people climb over the walls of American embassies, it's not a good sign. You're absolutely right. it is only four years since the fall of Saigon. You know, the scar of South Vietnam's fall has not healed by any means. And those scenes that the US Embassy must be, I mean, they are very fresh in people's minds. And there are no helicopters on hand.
然后令他惊恐的是，他看到他们开始翻越围墙。我想如果你是70年代的一名美国外交官，看到人们翻越美国大使馆的围墙，这绝不是什么好兆头。你说得完全对。距离西贡陷落才过去四年。你知道，南越陷落的伤疤绝未愈合。而美国大使馆发生的那些场景，我的意思是，在人们脑海中依然非常鲜活。而且手头没有直升机。
There are no helicopters cut. Well, as yet. Rosen goes back in, he says, bar the door, you know, I need to get rid of any sensitive papers. But actually, before he can do that, men are already forcing their way into his office. And he shouts at them in Farsi, get out or whatever. but more and more of them are coming in and one of them says to him leave immediately or you will be hurt
没有直升机。嗯，目前还没有。罗森回到里面，他说，把门锁上，你知道，我需要销毁任何敏感文件。但实际上，在他能做到这一点之前，男人们已经强行闯入了他的办公室。他用波斯语对他们大喊，滚出去之类的。但越来越多的人涌了进来，其中一个人对他说，立刻离开，否则你会受伤。
we are in control and Rosen can see they're very young they're very disorganised they are frightened of course and they're angry they're in a terrible state and he thinks well I'll just give in because this will be over soon I know how these things work
我们控制了这里。罗森能看出他们非常年轻，非常混乱，当然他们很害怕，也很愤怒，他们处于一种可怕的状态。他想，好吧，我还是顺从吧，因为这很快就会结束，我知道这些事情是怎么运作的。
I'm just going to have to set this up for the time being and he's led outside by these blokes and there are already hundreds of people pouring into the compound and they are moving around the buildings, they're going through all the cupboards, they're pulling out documents, all of this kind of thing.
我暂时只能这样了。他被这些家伙带到了外面，已经有数百人涌入大院，他们在建筑物里四处走动，翻遍了所有的橱柜，搜出了文件，诸如此类的事情。
In the Chancery building, the students demand that the staff open the safes. The staff don't have the combination. Some of the students start hitting them, and then they drag the staff outside, they bind them, they blindfold them, and this happens in every building in the compound.
在钱塞里大楼，学生们要求工作人员打开保险柜。工作人员没有密码。一些学生开始殴打他们，然后把工作人员拖到外面，捆绑起来，蒙上眼睛，大院里的每一栋楼都发生了这种情况。
It's a very confused and dramatic scene, but it all happens pretty quickly. An obvious question is why the Americans don't fight back. Why is there no shooting? And there are a couple of explanations. One is that not all the students are violent. So some of them carry signs in English that say, don't be afraid we just want to sit in.
这是一个非常混乱和戏剧性的场景，但一切发生得相当快。一个显而易见的问题是，为什么美国人没有反击？为什么没有枪声？有几种解释。一种是并非所有学生都是暴力的。所以他们中的一些人举着英文标语，上面写着“别害怕，我们只是想静坐”。
Right. So this is like Berkeley. This is like a student sit-in in California. Right, exactly. Or the London School of Economics or the sit-ins that have been so familiar in the 60s and 70s. Secondly, an obvious point, the Marines are massively outnumbered. I think there are about just over a dozen Marines in the compound.
对。所以这就像伯克利。这就像加利福尼亚的学生静坐。对，没错。或者伦敦政治经济学院，或者60和70年代人们非常熟悉的那些静坐。其次，一个显而易见的点是，海军陆战队的人数处于绝对劣势。我想大院里只有十几名海军陆战队员。
There are 300 students. You know, you're not going to shoot them all. So they're overwhelmed. But crucially, everybody thinks this will be over within hours because there have been attacks on the embassy before. You know, it's scary and it's, you know, traumatic, but it's not going to last forever. So by lunchtime, it's all over.
有300名学生。你知道，你不可能把他们全杀了。所以他们被压制了。但关键在于，每个人都认为这会在几小时内结束，因为大使馆以前也遭到过袭击。你知道，这很可怕，也很令人痛苦，但它不会永远持续下去。所以到午餐时间，一切都结束了。
The compound is now full of hundreds of Iranians and about 60 Americans have been taken prisoner. Most of them have been blindfolded or bound. Some of them are really, you know, they've been hit. They're bruised. They're battered. Some of them are terrified. They're going to be shot.
大院里现在挤满了数百名伊朗人，大约60名美国人被俘。他们大多数人被蒙上了眼睛或被捆绑。有些人真的，你知道，他们被打过。他们青一块紫一块，伤痕累累。有些人吓坏了。他们以为自己会被枪毙。
Some of them are saying to their friends, don't worry, it's fine. We'll probably be one of a plane going home tomorrow. This is how these things work. The chief diplomat, Bruce Lengen, and two of his senior officials are not there. They had a meeting at the Iranian Foreign Ministry. They went to the Foreign Ministry. Lengen found out what was going on. And he said, I want to see the Foreign Minister.
有些人对朋友说，别担心，没事的。我们明天可能就会坐飞机回家了。这些事情就是这样运作的。首席外交官布鲁斯·林根和他的两名高级官员不在那里。他们在伊朗外交部开会。他们去了外交部。林根发现了正在发生的事情。他说，我要见外交部长。
And they basically showed him into a dining room. And he was there for hours. And then he was there overnight. and then he was there for another day and then he basically realized I'm never getting out of this room and then does he get taken to the back to the embassy? No, they get shut up
他们基本上把他带进了一个餐厅。他在那里待了几个小时。然后他在那里过了一夜，接着又待了一天，然后他基本上意识到我永远也出不去这个房间了。然后他被带回大使馆了吗？不，他们被关在
in the foreign ministry forever forever. Well what happens to them? Do they get out as well in the end? Well they're hostages they're hostages but stuck in the foreign ministry not even with their maids back in the embassy well as we will see the hostages end up a lot of them end up getting spit up against solitary confinement and so on and so forth
外交部里，永远，永远。好吧，他们怎么样了？他们最后也出来了吗？嗯，他们是人质，他们是人质，但被困在外交部，甚至没有回到大使馆的仆人。嗯，正如我们将看到的，人质最终，很多人最终被分开进行单独监禁等等。
so they're all prisoners they've ended up as prisoners of the Iranian revolution. Of the 72 embassy staff, only six of them avoided capture. And this is an extraordinary story. Yeah, because this is the film, isn't it? This is Argo. There were five of them, Mark and Corolliak, Joseph and Kathleen Stafford, and Robert Anders, who were working in the consulate. The consulate building had a separate exit onto the street, so they were able to sneak out. Their original plan was to go to the British embassy, but there was a massive crowd outside the British embassy, so they had to abandon that. And after,
所以他们都是囚犯，他们最终成了伊朗革命的囚犯。在72名使馆工作人员中，只有6人逃脱了被捕。这是一个非凡的故事。是的，因为这就是那部电影，不是吗？这就是《逃离德黑兰》。当时有五个人，马克和科拉·利阿克，约瑟夫和凯瑟琳·斯塔福德，以及罗伯特·安德斯，他们在领事馆工作。领事馆大楼有一个通往街道的独立出口，所以他们能够溜走。他们最初的计划是去英国大使馆，但英国大使馆外有大量人群，所以他们不得不放弃。在经历了
of various goings on, they end up being taken in by the Canadians, as well as the sixth guy called Henry Lee Shats. And the story of how they're taken in by the Canadians, and then they get out of Iran, is the Ben Affleck film Argo. This extraordinary story, just to cut it a very long story short, the Canadians, who are the great heroes of this story, teamed up with a CIA agent called Tony Mendez, of course he was called Tony Mendez, and he created full-sight entities for them. They pretended they'd been working as Hollywood film scouts, checking out locations for a science fiction film called Argo. And the CIA went to the lengths of opening Hollywood studio to make this film. They made posters. They ran ads in variety in the Hollywood
各种波折后，他们最终被加拿大人收留，还有第六个人叫亨利·李·沙茨。他们被加拿大人收留并逃离伊朗的故事就是本·阿弗莱克的电影《逃离德黑兰》。这个非凡的故事，长话短说，作为这个故事伟大英雄的加拿大人，与一位名叫托尼·门德斯的中央情报局特工合作，当然他叫托尼·门德斯，他为他们伪造了完整的身份。他们假装是好莱坞电影制片人，正在为一部名为《逃离德黑兰》的科幻电影勘景。中情局甚至专门开设了一家好莱坞制片厂来制作这部电影。他们制作了海报。他们在好莱坞的《综艺》和《好莱坞报道》上刊登广告，为他们制造掩护故事。1980年1月，门德斯带着他的伪造工具包飞往伊朗，基本上把这些人救了出来。这真是一部好电影。是的。当时被称为“加拿大纸”。一个惊人的故事。我的意思是，我讲述这个故事的事实，如果你没看过这部电影，你可能已经猜到他们是否逃出来了，但这部电影仍然值得一看。我得说，德黑兰是拍摄惊悚片的绝佳地点。还有一部非常棒的以色列间谍剧叫《德黑兰》。
reporter to create a cover story for them. And Mendez, in January 1980, flies into Iran with his forgery kit to basically get these guys out. It's such a good film. Yeah. Canadian-Ca-Cat. paper it was called at the time. An amazing story. I mean, the fact that I'm telling the story, if you haven't seen the film, you can probably guess whether they get out or not, but it is still worth watching the film. I mean, I've got to say Tehran is an excellent place for thrillers. There's also a tremendous Israeli spy series called Tehran.
哦，是的，我记得你跟我们提起过，是的。摩萨德特工在德黑兰卧底。它实际上非常有勒卡雷的风格。双方在道德上都是矛盾的。我强烈推荐。而且它很紧张。特别是前两集，紧张程度和《逃离德黑兰》一模一样。
Oh, yeah, I remember you're telling us about that, yeah. Mossad agent who goes undercover in Tehran. It's actually very kind of Le Carre. Both sides are morally ambivalent. I really commend it. And it's intense. Particularly the first two episodes is incredibly tense in exactly the way that Argo is tense.
而且紧张，汤姆，我愿意相信这集也同样紧张，不是吗？是的，绝对。因为现在有66名人质被扣押，吉米·卡特现在头疼不已。所以他在戴维营，他的那种度假地。现在是凌晨4点，他接到了国务院的电话，
And tense, Tom, I would like to believe in the same way that this episode is tense, no? Yeah, absolutely. Because 66 hostages have now been left in captivity and Jimmy Carter now has a massive headache. So he's at Camp David, his sort of retreat. It's 4 o'clock in the morning and he gets the call from the State Department
说大使馆被占领了，有人被扣为人质。他放下电话，试图重新入睡，但因为显而易见的原因他睡不着。他曾明确询问过他的顾问，如果发生这种情况他们会怎么做，而他们没有给他明确的答案。他一定知道，即使在这个阶段，
that the embassy has been taken and people have been taken hostage. And he puts the phone down and he tries to get back to sleep. but he can't sleep for obvious reasons. He had specifically asked his advisers what they would do if this happened and they had not given him a clear answer. And he must know, even at this stage,
如果他找不到答案，那么他和他的总统任期就要进入历史的垃圾堆了。不是历史的垃圾堆。你知道吗？这是罗纳德·里根的形象。这就是我选择它的原因。多米尼克，好吧，你提到了紧张。是的，紧张，我们有。休息后回来看看吉米·卡特能否从垃圾堆里走出来。
that if he can't find an answer, then he and his presidency are heading for the dustbin of history. Not the dustbin of history. Do you know what? It's a Ronald Reagan image. That's why I chose it. Dominic, well, you said tension. Yeah, tension, we've got it. come back after the break to find out if Jimmy Carter can get out of the bin.
你好，欢迎回到《历史的其余部分》。我们离开时，美国大使馆正掌握在激进学生手中，大使馆里约66名美国人被扣为人质。那么，多米尼克，这些人质后来怎么样了？起初，记住人质们并不认为他们会成为长期人质。他们认为几小时内，也许一天，最坏的情况两三天就会被释放。起初，他们被关在大使馆大院里。他们在那里被关了很长时间，几周甚至几个月，直到伊朗人担心美国人可能会试图营救他们，于是把他们转移到了监狱。
Hello and welcome back to the rest of history. We left you with the United States Embassy in the hands of student militants and some 66 American hostages from that embassy being held hostage. So, Dominic, what happens to these hostages? So at first, remember the hostages don't think they're going to end up as long-term hostages. They think they will be out within hours, maybe a day, worst case, two or three days. At first, they are held in the embassy compound. And they were held there for a very long time, for weeks and months, until the Iranians became worried that the Americans might try to rescue them and they moved them to prisons.
他们把他们分开并转移到德黑兰各地的监狱。我提到了马克·鲍登的书《阿亚图拉的客人》。这是伊朗人使用的一个表达。他们说这些人是阿亚图拉的客人。但他们并没有被当作客人对待。他们被蒙上眼睛。他们经常受到审讯。他们受到欺凌。
They spit them up and moved them to prisons around Tehran. I mentioned Mark Bowden's book, Guests of the Ayatollah. This was an expression used by the Iranians. They said these people are the guests of Arias. But they weren't treated like guests. They were blindfolded. They were regularly interrogated. They were bullied.
他们受到殴打。人们会用枪指着他们的头。他们会假装和他们玩俄罗斯轮盘赌。他们会威胁要枪毙他们，除非他们承认自己是间谍并交出秘密。我惊讶于他们竟然会用“客人”这个词，因为好客在伊斯兰教中是非常重要的事情。这真是一个笑话，不是吗？
They were beaten. People would put guns to their heads. They would pretend to play Russian roulette with them. They would threaten to shoot them unless they admitted that they were spies and handed over secrets. I'm surprised they would use the word guests, actually, because hospitality is such a big deal in Islam. It's a joke, isn't it?
伊朗人在这次危机中的态度有一种嘲弄的意味。但好客的规则是如此重要。嗯，我的意思是，这对于伊朗的好客来说并不是一个很好的广告。尤其是因为劫持人质的人本身，当然他们很年轻，他们才二十出头。他们自己也很害怕，过度兴奋，组织混乱，
There's something mocking about the attitude of the Iranians. during this crisis. But the rules of hospitality are so important. Well, I mean this is not a great advert for Iranian hospitality. Not least because the hostage takers themselves, of course they're young, they're in their early twenties. They themselves are frightened, overexcited, disorganized,
脾气暴躁。他们花了很多时间对彼此和人质大喊大叫。一些人质，妇女和非裔美国人，在11月底几周后被释放了，显然是因为劫持者想表达一个政治观点。这就是伊朗革命中1968年的那一面。所以还剩下52人被扣押。
bad tempered. They spend a lot of time screaming at each other and at the hostages. Some of the hostages, the women and African Americans, were released before the end of November after a few weeks, obviously because the captors wanted to make a political point. This is the sort of 1968 side of the Iranian revolution. So that left 52 of them still in captivity.
他们的故事相当凄惨。我的意思是，他们中的许多人度过了一段非常非常糟糕的时光。他们经常被殴打。他们经常被捆绑数日。他们被带到嘲笑的人群面前。他们被分开并被单独监禁等等。而且他们总是戴着眼罩，不是吗？所以所有的照片里，他们总是。
And their story is a pretty grim one. I mean, a lot of them had a really, really terrible time. They were regularly beaten. They were regularly bound for days. They were brought out before jeering crowds. They were split up and put into solitary confinement and so on. And they're always wearing blindfolds, aren't they? So all the photographs, they're always.
我的意思是，太可怕了。当他们被转移到监狱时，他们度过了一段非常非常艰难的时光。监狱看守，也就是那些不是学生的人，监狱看守，他们殴打他们，折磨他们，诸如此类的事情。当然，最大的折磨莫过于这一切持续的时间太长了。所以现在有一个巨大的剧透警告。
I mean, just awful. And when they were moved to prisons, they had a really, really tough time. And the prison guards, so who were not students, the prison guards, they beat them, they tortured them, all of this kind of thing. And, of course, the greatest torment of all is just how long this goes on for. So a huge spoiler alert now.
这些人将被囚禁444天。所以比他们预想的，或者学生们预想的要长得多。我的意思是，这很有趣。所以问题是，为什么？这从来不是学生计划的一部分。为什么他们不放人？还有阿亚图拉的承诺呢，你知道，
These guys are going to be in captivity for 444 days. So far, far longer than they had envisaged or indeed the students had envisaged. I mean, this is the interesting thing. So the question is, why? This was never part of the student's plan. Why didn't they let them go? And what about the Ayatollah's promise that, you know,
“只要给我打个电话，我就能解决它”？嗯，这就是我们触及故事核心的地方，阿亚图拉。所以霍梅尼，尽管1979年和1980年美国报纸经常这样说，但霍梅尼几乎可以肯定对他们的计划一无所知，或者如果他知道什么，也只是最模糊的暗示，因为我们知道当他的外交部长去找他
just get on the phone to me and I'll sort it out? Well, this is where we get to the nub of the story, the Ayatollah. So Homini, despite what was often said in, you know, particularly American newspapers in 1979 and 1980, hominy almost certainly knew nothing about their plan or if he did know anything, the vaguest possible intimations of it because we know that when his foreign minister went to him
并说，这就是发生的事情。霍梅尼真的很惊讶，他说，我引用一下，“这些人是谁？他们为什么要这样做？去把他们赶走。”所以这是他在11月4日中午左右的最初反应。但到了那天晚上，他似乎已经改变了主意。
and said, this is what has happened. Homini was really surprised and he said, and I quote, who are these people? Why have they done this? Go and kick them out. So that was his initial reaction, sort of midday or so on the 4th of November. But by that evening he already seems to have changed his mind.
有一些暗示说这是因为他的儿子当时在德黑兰，他的儿子去了大使馆并汇报了情况。他说，学生们是你的忠实粉丝。他们是以你的名义做这件事的。人们喜欢它。德黑兰街头的反应是狂喜、欢乐、极度兴奋。每个人都认为这是一场了不起的政变。而且更重要的是，实际上在几天之内，大使馆就成了一个巨大的旅游景点。
And there are some suggestions that this has been, because his son was in Tehran and his son went to the embassy and reported back. He said, the students are massive fans of yours. They're doing this in your name. And people love it. The reaction on the streets of Tehran is one of delirium, of joy, of ecstasy. Everybody thinks this is the most tremendous coup. And what is more, actually, within days, the embassy becomes a massive tourist attraction.
大批人群前往。他们在庆祝和欢呼。有人在卖霍梅尼布道的磁带。他们是在买纪念品吗？是的。有人在卖纪念帽之类的东西。我的意思是，我读到了这个。我做了一些谷歌搜索，热情的谷歌搜索。
Great crowds will go. They're celebrating and cheering. There are people selling tapes of Khomeini's sermons. Are they kind of taking souvenirs? Yeah. There are people selling souvenir hats and stuff. I mean, I read this. And I did some Googling, enthusiastic Googling.
我不知道美国大使馆占领纪念帽会是什么样子。牛仔帽？不，我不知道。好吧，会是牛仔帽吗？我的意思是，谁在德黑兰制造牛仔帽？棒球帽？也许是棒球帽。我的意思是，这些帽子是……
I don't know what a souvenir U.S. Embassy seizure hat would look like. A Stetson? No, I don't. Well, would they be Stetsons? I mean, who's making Stetsons in Tehran? Baseball caps? Maybe baseball caps. I mean, are these hats that the...
伊朗人戴的吗？它们不是他们从美国大使馆拿走的帽子。不，美国大使馆里怎么可能有那么多帽子？我想美国大使馆大使戴一顶牛仔帽是必须的。当然，但我的意思是，那只有一顶牛仔帽。他们在卖很多帽子。总之，我们在帽子问题上跑题了，女帽业。汤姆，我们不是女帽业。
The Iranians are wearing? They're not hats that they've taken from the US embassy. No, how many hats could there have possibly been in the US embassy? I imagine it's obligatory for a US ambassador to have a Stetson. Surely, but I mean, that's only one Stetson. They're selling loads of hats. Anyway, we've got sidetracked into this hat issue, millinery. We're not the rest as millinery, Tom.
所以回到霍梅尼，我认为这是他政治技巧的一个很好的例子，他被低估的政治技巧，因为他看到这是维持他在街头控制力的完美象征性议题。因为他能把这一切拖得越久，对他越有利。这使得他临时政府中所谓的温和派看起来有点软弱无力，并允许更极端的分子，强硬派，革命委员会，建立支持。所以巴克·莫温的霍梅尼传记引用了他与朋友的谈话。
So to go back to Chomini, this is a good example, I think, of his political skill, his underrated political skill, because he sees this is the perfect symbolic issue to maintain his hold on the streets. because the longer he can spin all this out, the better for him. It makes the sort of so-called moderates in his interim government look a bit weak and feeble, and it allows the more extreme elements, the hardline elements, the revolutionary committees, to build support. So Bakr Mowin's biography of Khomeini quotes him talking to a friend.
“我们扣留人质，完成我们的内部工作，然后释放他们。这团结了我们的人民。我们可以毫无困难地将宪法付诸全民公投，并进行总统和议会选举。当我们完成所有这些工作后，我们就可以释放人质了。”换句话说，我们扣留他们是为了巩固我们对伊朗的控制。你认为这在视觉上也是为了确保你的敌人不会采取任何行动吗？尽管也许美国在这个阶段并没有计划军事入侵之类的，但扣留人质可能会在伊朗革命者的潜意识中产生一种感觉，即他们的革命正受到威胁。
We keep the hostages, finish our internal work, then release them. This is united our people. We can put the Constitution to the people's vote without difficulty and carry out the presidential and parliamentary elections. And when we've finished all these jobs, then we can let the hostages go. So in other words, we keep them for as long as we need to cement our control of Iran. And do you think also the optics of it is that you keep a hostage to ensure that your enemy won't do anything? And even though perhaps the United States were not planning by this stage a military. invasion or anything, it might generate subliminally in the minds of Iranian revolutionaries
是的，可能，可能，当然可能会给你一点安全感，你知道吗？是的。美国人现在不会攻击我们，因为我们扣押了他们52个人作为人质。现在，劫持人质的人确实有一份要求清单。他们希望美国交出沙阿接受审判。他们希望美国就1953年的政变正式道歉，所以又是那种历史感，
the sense that their revolution is under threat by holding the hostages. Yeah, possibly, possibly, and of course might give you a little bit of security, you know? Yeah. The Americans won't attack us now because we have 52 of their people held hostage. Now, the hostage takers did have a list of demands. They wanted the United States to hand over the Shah for trial. They wanted the Americans to issue a formal apology for the coup of 1953. so that sort of sense of history again,
他们希望美国银行解冻伊朗所有被冻结的资产。但我认为这些要求完全无关紧要，这是美国人从未真正意识到的，白宫、国务院从未完全明白，这些要求是不相关的，因为霍梅尼和神职人员根本不想释放人质。他们太有用了，因为他立刻就得到了结果。
and they wanted American banks to release all Iran's frozen assets. But I think these demands are completely beside the point, and this is something that Americans never really realized that the White House, the State Department, could never quite get into their heads, that the demands were irrelevant because Khomeini and the clerics didn't want to release the hostages. They were too useful, because right away he gets results.
巴扎尔甘的临时政府，那个留着山羊胡的家伙和所有这些人，在使馆被占领几天后就辞职了。他们对使馆被占领感到震惊。他们辞职了，霍梅尼想，太棒了，因为基本上现在强硬派可以不受挑战地以我的名义行使权力，这正是他想要的。但我认为美国人并没有真正意识到这一点。
The interim government of Barzagan, the goatee-bearded guy and all these people, they resigned days after the embassy seizure. They were shocked by the embassy seizure. They resigned and Khomeini thought, well, brilliant, because basically now the hardliners are left unchallenged to wield power in my name, which is what he wanted. But the Americans, I think, didn't really realize this.
华盛顿的大多数人认为伊朗人会热衷于谈判。在国务院，工作假设是，这可能完全是关于钱的问题，我们可以达成协议，我们可以释放被冻结的伊朗银行资产，这样我们就能让人质回来，这需要几周，最坏的情况几个月，但这完全是可行的。
Most people in Washington thought that the Iranians would be keen to negotiate. And in the State Department, the working assumption was, probably this is all about money and we can do a deal, we can release frozen Iranian bank assets and that way we'll get the hostages back and this will take weeks, worst case months, but it's perfectly doable.
事实上，疯狂的是，卡特的一些连任团队成员认为这对他有利。所以他将面临来自查帕奎迪克的泰德·肯尼迪的挑战。他们认为，这会让卡特有机会披上国旗。肯尼迪在玩政治。好吧，你知道，总统正在为这些人质尽其所能。卡特的幕僚长汉密尔顿·乔丹说，
And in fact, the mad thing, some of Carter's re-election team thought this would work in his favour. So he's going to be facing a challenge from Chappaquiddix, Ted Kennedy. And they think, well, this will allow Carter to wrap himself in the flag. Kennedy is playing politics. Well, you know, the president is doing all he can for the hostages. And Carter's chief of staff, Hamilton Jordan, said,
“让我们把这事放在头版。”这太疯狂了。这是最糟糕的策略。我知道。我知道。这是一个疯狂的策略。他说，我引用一下，“这将为卡特和我们来自马萨诸塞州的朋友在如何处理危机方面提供一个很好的对比。”哦，天哪。我的意思是，他们两个在危机中表现都不太好。这必须得说。不。所以卡特非常认真地对待这件事。他睡不着觉。他总是去参加祈祷会。他坚持亲自会见所有人质的家属。他的助手们开始非常担心他。他们说，你知道，他总是不断地谈论人质，参加所有这些会议。我认为这其中很大一部分是内疚。因为当国会领导人问他时，
let's keep this on the front pages. That's mad. That's the worst strategy. I know. I know. It is a mad strategy. He said, I quote, it will provide a nice contrast between Carter and our friend from Massachusetts and how to handle a crisis. Oh, God. I mean, neither of them are very good in the crisis. That has to be said. No. So Carter takes this. whole of business incredibly seriously. He can't sleep. He's always going off to prayer meetings. He insists him personally meeting the families of all the hostages. His aides become quite worried about him. They say, you know, he's just constantly going on about the hostages, having all these meetings. And a lot of this, I think, is guilt. Because when he was asked by congressional leaders,
“你知道，接纳沙阿是我们的错吗？”他非常粗暴地对他们说，“我不在乎你是否喜欢沙阿。”这种急躁向我表明，他感到个人责任，因为他接纳了沙阿，他其实并不想这样做，他屈服了，他让沙阿进来了，这就是结果。然而，在短期内，奇怪的是，这确实对他有利，因为这是人质危机叙述中经常被忽略的一点。1979年11月，他的支持率大幅上升。好吧，因为你团结在国旗下，不是吗？是的，完全正确。我的意思是，就像9-11之后，灾难性的情报失败。每个人都认为布什很出色。是的，完全正确。但这种受欢迎程度的激增
you know, is this kind of our fault for admitting the Shah? He snapped at them in a very, I don't give a damn whether or not you like the Shah, he said. And the tetchiness suggests to me that he feels personally responsible because he admitted the Shah, he didn't really want to do it, he gave in, he let the Shah in, and this is the result. However, in the short term, oddly, it does work in his favour because this is a thing that's often sort of elided in accounts of the hostage crisis. There was a big jump in his approval rating in November 1979. Well, because you rallied to the flag, don't you? Yeah, exactly. I mean, it's like in the wake of 9-11, disastrous, intelligent failure. Everyone thinks Bush is brilliant. Yes, exactly. But this sort of spike in his popularity
只有在他救出人质的情况下才能持续。如果他不救出他们，它注定会消退。另一件事是，他想做的和他幕僚长想做的，他们想让他的总统任期现在完全围绕让人质回家，因为他们认为这对他有利。但这太鲁莽了。因为如果他把他的总统任期抵押给德黑兰那些他不了解的人的决定。现在，另一件事是，
will only be sustainable if he gets the hostages out. If he doesn't get them out, it's bound to fade. And the other thing is, what he wants to do and what his chief of staff wants to do, they want to make his presidency now all about getting the hostages home, because they think it will work in his favour. But that's so reckless. because if he's mortgaging his presidency to the decisions of people in Tehran that he doesn't understand. Now, the other thing is,
我说他不了解的人，华盛顿仍然没有人了解阿亚图拉霍梅尼。我的意思是，你在我们之前的剧集中谈到了阿亚图拉的末日感，他的，你知道，那种末世论、神学愿景的红色、原始强度。华盛顿没有人对此有丝毫感觉。
I say people he doesn't understand, nobody in Washington still understands the Ayatollah Khomeini. I mean, you were talking in our previous episodes about the Ayatollah's, his apocalyptic sense, his, you know, the sort of, the red, raw intensity of his eschatological, theological vision. No one in Washington has the slightest sense of this.
我的意思是，国家安全委员会的伊朗专家加里·西克后来写道。加里·西克。加里·西克是他的名字。没有人知道霍梅尼是什么样的人。他简直超出了美国政府中任何人的经验，如果不是想象力的话。他们对此毫无感觉。然后霍梅尼做了他们没想到的事，他喜欢这样。他将其个性化，
I mean, the National Security Council's Iran specialist guy called Gary Sick wrote afterwards. Gary Sick. Gary Sick was his name. Nobody knew what kind of person Khomeini was. He was simply beyond the experience, if not the imagination of anyone in the United States government. They have no sense of this. And what Khomeini then does, which they didn't expect, he loves this. and he personalises it
并将其变成了他自己和吉米·卡特之间的决斗。所以霍梅尼在占领美国大使馆后几乎立刻接受了美国三大电视网的采访。他完全镇定自若。他完全不悔改。他说人质是间谍。这全是卡特的错。是卡特这个罪犯违反了国际法，
and he makes it into a duel between himself and Jimmy Carter. So Khomeini gave interviews to all three American networks pretty much straight after the seizure of the US embassy. He was completely unflappable. He was completely unrepentant. He said the hostages were spies. This is all Carter's fault. It's Carter, who's the criminal breaking international law
接纳了沙阿。他嘲笑卡特。这又是，你认为阿亚图拉是如此冷酷和令人生畏，他当然是。但我不得不说，他身上确实有一点校园恶霸的影子。他明确表示，卡特是在敲空鼓。
by admitting the Shah. And he mocked Carter. This is, again, you think of the attaerola as so grim and formidable, which of course he was. But there is a sort of, there's a bit of the school bully in him, I have to say. He says explicitly, Carter is beating an empty drum.
卡特没有胆量进行军事行动。软弱，软弱，软弱。是的。但我同时也想知道，是否没有，你知道，我们谈到了阿亚图拉拥有的那种末日愿景。
Carter does not have the guts to engage in military action. Weak, weak, week. Yeah. But I wonder also, though, whether there isn't, you know, we talked about this apocalyptic vision that the Ayatollah has.
我认为伊朗什叶派深受琐罗亚斯德教和摩尼教那种二元论传统的影响，这种感觉世界被划分为善与恶的竞争力量。他不仅是在妖魔化卡特。他也在字面上妖魔化美国，因为在学生占领美国大使馆的第二天，他创造了这个词，“大撒旦”。我相信我们的大多数听众都会感觉到“大撒旦”是伊斯兰激进分子最常用来形容美国的词。
And Iranian Shiasam, I think, is massively influenced by this kind of the dualist traditions of Zoroastrianism and manicureism, this sense of the world divided into rival forces of good and evil. And he's not just demonizing Carteries. He is also literally demonizing America, because the day after the students occupy the U.S. Embassy, he coins this phrase, the great Satan. And I'm sure most of our listeners will have a sense of the great Satan as the phrase that is most often used by Islamic militants to describe America.
问题是这不是《古兰经》里的词。阿亚图拉似乎基本上是编造出来的。在《古兰经》中，撒旦的形象并不是基督徒所熟悉的那种形象，那种可怕的恶魔形象，与神圣的善的力量争夺世界统治权。但撒旦是一种诱惑者。他是诱导虔诚的穆斯林偏离正义之路的人。
And the thing is that this isn't a Quranic phrase. The Ayatollahs basically seems to have made it up. And in the, I mean, in the Quran, the figure of Satan isn't the figure that would be familiar to kind of Christians, the sense of a terrifying demonic figure, contesting the rule of the world with, you know, the divine forces of good. But Satan is a kind of a tempter. He's the person who seduces devout Muslims from, from the path of righteousness.
但我认为阿亚图拉正在把撒旦的形象变成一种，你知道，摩尼教式的邪恶形象。这就是美国对他而言的样子。当然，在美国，你也有这种摩尼教式的善恶观。双方现在都开始认为对方是邪恶的字面宇宙代表。
But I think the Ayatollah is kind of making the figure of Satan into a kind of, you know, a Manichaean figure of evil. And that's what America becomes for him. And of course, in America as well, you also have this Manichian sense of good and evil. And both sides now are starting to think of the other as a literal cosmic representation. of evil.
是的，我认为这是真的，因为记住在美国，我们在上一集中说过，美国电视网以前每年只花五分钟报道伊朗。报道沙阿去滑雪。我的意思是，现在这成了巨大的电视奇观。所以我们在之前的系列中谈过，例如开膛手杰克系列，媒体在构建危机和创造故事方面有多重要，以及在调解所有这些事情、构建故事方面有多重要。我想是这样。这是一个非常好的例子，因为美国电视网都开始播放关于人质危机的特别节目。
Yeah, I think that's true, because remember that in America, we were saying in a previous episode, American TV networks previously devoted five minutes a year to Iran. To the Shah going skiing. I mean, now this becomes this huge TV spectacle. So we've talked in previous series, for example, the Jack the Ripper series, about how important the media can be in kind of framing a crisis and creating a story and how important is that mediating all these things, constructing stories. I suppose. And this is a really good example because the American networks all start running special
ABC带头，他们有一个节目叫《美国被扣为人质》。它每天晚上都播出。这个节目的每一期都以“第57天，第58天”开始。你知道，那种滴答作响的时钟感。我认为整件事令人极其不安。伊朗的场景对美国观众来说似乎比红场的场景更陌生。是的，因为他们穿着军装，像那种西方制服。我会说，有一种难以置信的陌生感。你在威奇托、堪萨斯或其他什么地方看着它。
programs about the hostage crisis. So ABC led the way they had a show called America held hostage. It ran every single night. And every edition of this show began day 57, day 58. You know, the sort of sense of a ticking clock. I think the whole thing is incredibly unsettling. And the scenes from Iran seem much more alien to American views. viewers, then say the scenes of Red Square. Yes, because they're in military uniforms, like kind of Western uniforms. There was something unbelievably alien, I would say. You're watching it in, you know, Wichita, Kansas or something.
就你而言，这可能发生在异星球上。你谈到了摩尼教。善与恶的感觉是如此重要。我们已经提到这距离南越陷落才四年，在一个如此混乱、肮脏且道德模糊的故事结束之后，美国经常被描绘成反派。许多美国人相信他们就是反派。这是一个对美国人来说似乎黑白分明、善恶分明的故事。
This might as well be happening on an alien planet as far as you're concerned. And you talked about the Maneism. The good versus evil sense of it is so important. We already mentioned this is only four years after the fall of South Vietnam, after the end of a story that was so confused and grubby and morally ambiguous in which America was often painted as the villain. And many Americans believe that they were the villains. And this is a story in which it seems to Americans, this is clear cut, good versus evil.
有清白的人质，其中许多人只有20多岁，还有那些高喊着“大撒旦”的咆哮暴徒。我的意思是，这是一个故事。它有巨大的穿透力。人质的家属，人质的母亲，成了电视明星。所以当某个人质可能被拖到电视上时，在美国电视上，他的母亲就会被拖出来，她会对着镜头哭泣等等。
There are clean cut hostages, many of whom are in their 20s, and there are these howling mobs shouting about the great Satan. I mean, it's a story. It had colossal cut through. the families, the mothers of the hostages, became TV stars. So when a particular hostage might be dragged out on TV, on American TV, his mother would then be dragged out, and she would be crying for the cameras and whatnot.
有一位母亲去了伊朗，叫芭芭拉·蒂姆。她的儿子凯文是最小的人质。他是一名海军陆战队员。她进入了德黑兰。她见了他45分钟，和他谈论了他高中篮球队的命运，我相信他们打进了威斯康星州锦标赛。
There was a mother who went to Iran called Barbara Tim. Her son, Kevin, was the youngest hostage. She was a Marine. She got into Tehran. She got to see him for 45 minutes and talked to him about the fortunes of his high school basketball team, who had made, I believe, the Wisconsin State. Championships.
那一定让他振作起来了。这就是他们谈论的内容。我的意思是，我必须说，提到越南，你知道，有反战左派的传统。有一些，我们称之为，色彩鲜艳的访客去了德黑兰。简·方达没去。不，但一些越南人，一些神职人员，一些左翼神职人员去了。所以在圣诞节，人质们享受了由这些神职人员带领的访问，由一位资深
That must have cheered him up. That's what they talked about. I mean, there also, I have to say, some very, mentioning Vietnam, you know, there is that tradition of the anti-war left. There are some, so we say, colourful visitors to Tehran. Jane Fonda doesn't go. No, but some Vietnam, some clergymen, some lefty clergymen go. So at Christmas, the hostages had the treat of a visit from these clergymen led by a veteran
和平活动家威廉·斯隆·科芬领导。所以你有外交官叫西克。你有神职人员叫科芬。但等等。这令人难以置信。这个家伙出现了，他见了人质，他对他们说，你知道，他们期待着美国牧师的鼓舞人心的信息，而他说，“停止自怜吧。”他说，“我羡慕你们有这么长一段时间的平静来休息和思考。”人质们目瞪口呆地听着。然后当会议结束时，他走到镜头前，在美国电视上说，“是的，我们对人质大喊大叫，但很少有美国人听到被折磨的伊朗人的尖叫声。”这种事情，显然，人质不想听到这个。然后实际上，可能比这更糟。
peace activist called William Sloan Coffin. And he, so you've got diplolyn. Matt's called sick. You've got clergyman called coffin. But wait for it. This is unbelievable. This bloke turned up and he met the hostages and he said to them, you know, they were hoping for an inspiring message from an American priest and he said, stop feeling sorry for
几周后，另一群激进活动家访问了大使馆，他们由一个名叫约翰·托马斯的美国原住民活动家领导，名字好得没法改。约翰·托马斯，他之前在1973年占领过伤膝河。现在他带领伊朗人群高喊“打倒”。我以为你要说“打倒卡斯特”。是的，好吧，那是美国大使馆。
yourselves. He said, I envy you having an extended period of peace and quiet to rest and think. And their hostages listen to this in stupefaction. And then when the meeting was over, he went to front of the cameras and he said on American TV, yeah, we scream and shout about the hostages. but very few Americans heard the screams of tortured Iranians. And this kind of thing, obviously, the hostages don't want to hear this. And then actually, it possibly even worse than this.
所以也许他被听错了。也许他在喊“打倒卡斯特”，谁知道呢。总之，所有人质兴趣的巅峰出现在圣诞节。所以我提到了布鲁斯·林根，他是被扣押在外交部的最高级别外交官。他的妻子佩妮接受了《华盛顿邮报》的一次非常感人的采访。他受到特殊待遇了吗？也许待遇稍微好一点，但仍然不怎么样。是的，好吧。
A few weeks later, another group of radical activists visited the embassy, and they were led by a guy who was a Native American activist with the unimprovable name of John Thomas. And John Thomas, he'd previously occupied Wounded Knee in 1973. And now he led the Iranian crowd chanting death. DeKata. I thought you were going to say death to custer. Yes, well, yeah, that's at the US embassy.
我认为他们被关在外交部的事实意味着情况不像其他地方那么糟糕，但也不是什么乐事。所以他的妻子佩妮说，你知道，这是一个非常，只要你不那么愤世嫉俗，这是一个非常感人的采访。她说，“我会像往常一样用花环和降临节蜡烛装饰我们的房子，因为那是布鲁斯希望我做的。”她说，“我在布鲁斯的囚禁中通过敲响当地教堂的钟声来寻求安慰。我希望其他人也能这样做。我认为这是一个如此可爱的象征。它传达了希望和欢乐。”像圣女贞德一样。
So maybe he was misheard. Maybe he was shouting death to custer, who knows. Anyway, the peak of all the sort of interest in the hostages came at Christmas. So I mentioned Bruce Lengen, who was the most senior diplomat taken hostage in the foreign ministry. His wife, Penny, gave a very moving interview to the Washington Post. Does he get special treatment or not? Perhaps slightly better treatment, but still not great. Yeah, okay.
嗯，有点像圣女贞德。人们确实这样做了，实际上。人们对此非常感动。然后她说，“我们在花园里有一棵老橡树，我在上面系了一条黄丝带。”她说，她受到1973年一首排名第一的单曲的启发，
I think the fact that they're in the foreign ministry meant it wasn't quite as bad as elsewhere, but it wasn't a bundle of laughs. So his wife Penny said, you know, it's a very kind of, as long as you're not too cynical, it's a very touching interview. She says, I'm going to be decorating our house with a wreath and advent candles as normal because that's what Bruce want me to do. She says, I take comfort in Bruce's captivity from reing the bells at my local church. I hope other people will do the same. I think it's such a lovely symbol. It conveys hope and joy. Like Joan of Arc.
那就是托尼·奥兰多和黎明合唱团的《在老橡树上系一条黄丝带》。因为我不想太愤世嫉俗，我无法让自己去听它，因为我担心如果我听了，你会啜泣。不，我担心我会以一种残酷和冷漠的方式嘲笑，我不想那样做。所以这首歌的灵感来自于关于美国内战中美国骑兵的故事。
Well, a bit like Joan of Arc. And people did do this, actually. People were very moved by this. And then she says, we've got an old oak tree in the garden, and I've tied a yellow ribbon around it. And she's inspired, she says, by a number one single from 1973,
爱人是骑兵的女性会在头发上系黄丝带。据说如此。老橡树是怎么进来的？嗯，佩妮·林根在这棵橡树上系了一条黄丝带。是的，但在歌里。不，她是受这首歌的启发。我知道，但如果女性在头发上系黄丝带，她们是怎么想到歌里的橡树的？
which was tie a yellow ribbon around the old oak tree by Tony Orlando and Dawn. Because I don't want to be too cynical, I can't bring myself to listen to it because I'm worried that if I listen to it, you'll sob. No, I'm worried I will scoff in a cruel and an unfeeling way, and I don't want to do that. So this song was inspired by stories about the US cavalry in the American Civil War.
那就是托尼·奥兰多与黎明合唱团演唱的《在老橡树上系一条黄丝带》。因为我不想表现得太愤世嫉俗，所以我没法让自己去听这首歌，因为我担心如果我听了，你会哭出来。不，我是担心我会以一种残忍且冷漠的方式嘲笑它，而我不想那样做。所以这首歌的灵感来源于美国内战时期关于美国骑兵的故事。
Women whose sweethearts were cavalrymen would wear yellow ribbons in their hair. So it is said. How did the old oak tree come into it? Well, Penny Langan tied a yellow ribbon around this oak tree. Yeah, but in the song. No, she was inspired by the song. I know, but if the women are tying yellow ribbons in their hair, how did they come up with the idea for the oak tree in the song?
恋人是骑兵的女性会在头发上系黄丝带。据说如此。那老橡树是怎么扯上关系的呢？嗯，佩妮·兰根在这棵橡树上系了一条黄丝带。是的，但在歌里呢？不，她是受了这首歌的启发。我知道，但如果女人们是在头发上系黄丝带，那歌里关于橡树的想法是怎么来的呢？
It's her idea. That's her idea. No, it's not. It's the idea of Tony Orlando and Dawn. You'll have to ask Tony Orlando and Dawn how they made the leap from the ribbon in the hair to the ribbon around the tree. I mean, it's quite a leap. If there are any musicologists out there, let us know.
这是她的主意。那是她的主意。不，不是。那是托尼·奥兰多与黎明合唱团（Tony Orlando and Dawn）的主意。你得去问问托尼·奥兰多与黎明合唱团，他们是怎么从“发间的丝带”联想到“树上的丝带”的。我的意思是，这跨度相当大。如果有音乐学家在听的话，请告诉我们。
The important fact is that she tied the yellow ribbon around her oak tree And then she said, one of these days, Bruce is going to untie that yellow ribbon and it's going to be out there until he does. And Tom, if you don't have a tear in your eye listening to this, there's something wrong with you. Lots of people did anyway, even if you didn't. Hey, I do find that affecting. They tied it to trees. They tied them to lamp post. They tied them to flags.
重点是，她在橡树上系了一条黄丝带，然后她说，总有一天，布鲁斯会解开那条黄丝带，在那之前它会一直挂在那里。汤姆，如果你听了这些还没热泪盈眶，那你肯定有什么问题。不管怎样，很多人都这么做了，即使你没做。嘿，我确实觉得这很感人。他们把丝带系在树上，系在灯柱上，系在旗帜上。
Jimmy Carter put a yellow ribbon on his Christmas tree. You see, that's a political error, isn't it? Well, he said he also, this is typical miserableism from Jimmy Carter. He said, I'm not going to turn on the lights on the Christmas tree. Or the heating. Yes. His thermostat is set at zero or whatever. He's traveling on the bus to save energy.
吉米·卡特在他的圣诞树上系了一条黄丝带。你看，那是个政治错误，对吧？嗯，他说他还要——这是吉米·卡特典型的悲惨主义——他说，我不会点亮圣诞树上的灯。也不会开暖气。是的。他的恒温器设在零度还是什么的。他坐公交车出行以节省能源。
He doesn't turn on the, he says, I'm not going to turn on the lights on the Christmas tree until the hostages come home. He says they don't come home. Does that mean he's got to leave the Christmas tree up until they come home? No, I don't think he does that. Tabby is pointing out that Jimmy Carter's cardigans would keep him warm. So no wonder who's got the thermostat down. Actually, there was a yellow ribbon.
他说，在人质回家之前，我不会点亮圣诞树上的灯。他说他们没回家。那是不是意味着他得一直留着圣诞树直到他们回家？不，我不认为他会那样做。塔比指出，吉米·卡特的开衫毛衣能让他保暖。所以难怪是谁把恒温器调低了。其实，当时确实有一条黄丝带。
So at the Super Bowl, Steelers versus Rams. There was a huge yellow ribbon tied around the stadium. Wow. Americans must think it's mad that we're laughing at this. But anyway, I'm not laughing at it. You are. So, I mean, I don't want to laugh at the hostage crisis, obviously. There are some mad things connected with it, though.
在超级碗比赛中，钢人队对阵公羊队。体育场周围系了一条巨大的黄丝带。哇。美国人一定觉得我们嘲笑这件事很疯狂。但无论如何，我并没有嘲笑它。是你。所以，我的意思是，我显然不想嘲笑人质危机。不过，这其中确实有一些疯狂的事情。
So there were pro-war demonstrations on college campuses. So there were students, for example, Ohio. State chanting Nagasaki Hiroshima, why not Iran? I mean, that's a change from the Vietnam War protests. Princeton, students waving bed sheets in which they'd written Newk the Ayatollah. There were some mad songs. So I know you like a song. Are you familiar with Take Your Royal and shove it by Bobby Baker? No, Dominic, I'm not, but I am familiar with that great song by the Baratone dwarfs. Bomb, bomb, bomb, bomb, Iran. Yes.
当时大学校园里有支持战争的示威活动。例如，俄亥俄州立大学的学生高呼“长崎、广岛，为什么不是伊朗？”。我的意思是，这与越战抗议活动相比是个转变。普林斯顿大学的学生挥舞着床单，上面写着“核平阿亚图拉”。当时还有一些疯狂的歌曲。我知道你喜欢歌。你熟悉鲍比·贝克的《去你的，阿亚图拉》（Take Your Ayatollah and shove it）吗？不，多米尼克，我不熟悉，但我熟悉男中音矮人合唱团那首伟大的歌，《炸、炸、炸、炸，伊朗》。是的。
Based on Barbaran by the Beach Boys. Do you know, there were more than, I think there were six different Balmiran songs done by different bands, all based on the Beach Boys, Barbara Ann. Not good news for the hostages if Tehran gets nuk. No, it wouldn't be good news. And also, you know, I mean,
基于海滩男孩的《芭芭拉·安》。你知道吗，我想有六首不同的“炸伊朗”歌曲，由不同的乐队演唱，全部基于海滩男孩的《芭芭拉·安》。如果德黑兰被核平，这对人质来说可不是好消息。不，那不会是好消息。而且，你知道，我的意思是，
you can kind of understand the Aetollahs wanting their own nuclear weapon. Nuclear weapon. Well, they've been provoked because American toy companies have started selling dolls of the Ayatollah. You've seen this? And I'm going to read you the advertising copy. Available for those who want to strike back. Make him you're a prisoner.
你可以理解阿亚图拉想要他们自己的核武器。核武器。嗯，他们被激怒了，因为美国玩具公司开始销售阿亚图拉玩偶。你见过这个吗？我要给你读读广告文案。提供给那些想要反击的人。让他成为你的囚犯。
Act now. Get rope, pins, other torture equipment. Oh, God. And then the words. And then the words, fabulous gift item. Imagine your child opening that at Christmas. Oh, thanks, mommy. But then my favorite story, there was a brothel in the arena.
立即行动。获取绳子、大头针和其他酷刑设备。天哪。还有这些话。还有这些话，“绝佳的礼品”。想象一下你的孩子在圣诞节拆开这个。哦，谢谢妈妈。但接下来是我最喜欢的故事，竞技场里有一家妓院，
called the Mustang Ranch. And they put up a sign on the door that said, no more Iranian students will be permitted on these premises until the hostages are released. How many Iranian students were going to the Mustang Ranch? I mean, I don't know how much custom they were losing through that making a stand. Now, on a more serious note,
叫“野马牧场”。他们在门上贴了一个牌子，上面写着：“在人质获释之前，禁止伊朗学生进入本场所。”有多少伊朗学生会去野马牧场？我的意思是，我不知道他们通过这种立场损失了多少生意。现在，说点严肃的，
what's happened to the most controversial Iranian living in America? Not, I think, a client at the Mustang Ranch. they're somebody who was not a stranger to the escort industry. And this is the Shah. The Shah, you may remember, had arrived at the Cornell Medical Center for Emergency Treatment. He had complications from the surgery. The cancer didn't go away. There was more suffering ahead because he had to endure bedside visits from Henry Kissenter and Frank Sinatra.
那个生活在美国的最具争议的伊朗人怎么样了？我想他不是野马牧场的常客。他们是与护送行业并不陌生的人。这就是国王。你可能还记得，国王抵达康奈尔医疗中心接受紧急治疗。他手术后出现了并发症。癌症没有消失。他还要忍受亨利·基辛格和弗兰克·辛纳屈的床边探视，未来还有更多的痛苦。
Will the torture never end? Well, it didn't actually. What's Frank Sinatra doing turning up? I mean, I actually quite like Frank Sinatra if I was in hospital. Really? Well, you see me, so, yeah. Yeah, I think Frank Sinatra at this point, has moved to the right, I'm guessing, because he's quite pallied with Reagan.
这种折磨什么时候才能结束？嗯，实际上并没有结束。弗兰克·辛纳屈跑去干什么？我的意思是，如果我在医院，我其实挺喜欢弗兰克·辛纳屈的。真的吗？嗯，你看到我了，所以，是的。是的，我想弗兰克·辛纳屈此时已经转向右翼了，我猜，因为他和里根关系很好。
So, and maybe showing solidarity with the Shah is part of Frank Sinatra's vibe. Maybe he's just a hospital visitor. Maybe. So the Carter administration, still not terribly keen on the Shah. They basically kicked him out again. They said, we want you to go. And in December they array, said, we've arranged for you to go to Panama. So he moved to Panama.
所以，也许对国王表示声援是弗兰克·辛纳屈氛围的一部分。也许他只是个医院访客。也许吧。所以卡特政府仍然不太喜欢国王。他们基本上又把他赶走了。他们说，我们要你走。12月，他们说，我们已经安排你去巴拿马了。于是他搬到了巴拿马。
And the dictator of Panama at the time, General Torrijos, was not a good host. he charged the Shah $21,000 a day for bored and lodging, which seems harsh. And he also, I think the expression is, trolled the Shah by appointing to supervise him in his Exar a Marxist sociology professor. That's the worst kind of professor. Exactly. And the worst kind of Marxist, the worst kind of sociologist, the worst kind of professor. Every day the Shah would get up feeling incredibly sorry for himself and ill,
当时的巴拿马独裁者托里霍斯将军不是个好东道主。他向国王收取每天21,000美元的食宿费，这看起来很苛刻。而且我还认为，用现在的表达方式，他通过指派一名马克思主义社会学教授来监督流亡的国王，是在“钓鱼”羞辱他。那是教授中最糟糕的一种。没错。而且是最糟糕的马克思主义者，最糟糕的社会学家，最糟糕的教授。国王每天起床都感到非常自怜和痛苦，
and this bloke was hanging around lecturing him about the evils of him. imperialism. The Shah was still, he still thought he would get back to Iran. So General Tarrios in Panama, as part of his sort of winding the Shah up, said to him, you're a bit like Napoleon in exile, aren't you? You're like Napoleon on St Helena. And the Shah said no, because Napoleon never got back. But I will. My dynasty will prevail. Well, time will tell, I guess. As we record this, who knows? So he ends up, finally he moves on from there to Egypt. He's very, very ill indeed. The cancer was spread and the Shah died on the 27th of July 1980. His last words supposedly, which he whispered again and again, were Iran is Iran, which is exactly what, you know,
而这个家伙就在旁边徘徊，向他宣讲帝国主义的罪恶。国王仍然认为他能回到伊朗。所以巴拿马的托里霍斯将军，作为他折磨国王的一部分，对他说：“你有点像流亡中的拿破仑，不是吗？你就像圣赫勒拿岛上的拿破仑。”国王说不，因为拿破仑再也没能回去。但我会。我的王朝会延续。好吧，我想时间会证明一切。在我们录制这段节目时，谁知道呢？所以他最终从那里搬到了埃及。他病得非常非常重。癌症扩散了，国王于1980年7月27日去世。据说他反复低语的遗言是“伊朗就是伊朗”，我想这正是你希望他说的。伊斯兰共和国的反应，可能不像人们希望的那样优雅。对。所以伊朗官方通讯社发表声明说，他在耻辱、痛苦和流浪中死去。德黑兰电台说，世纪吸血鬼终于死了。这太刻薄了。我的意思是，公平地说，他是个吸血鬼。他是吗？是的。
you would want him to say, I suppose. The reaction from the Islamic Republic, probably not as gracious as one would hope. Right. So the official Iranian news agency issued a statement, he died in disgrace, misery and vagrancy. And Radio Tehran, the bloodsucker of of the century has died at last. So that's harsh. I mean, he was a bloodsucker, to be fair. He was? Yeah.
这太刻薄了。嗯，他吸血。我的意思是，他在庆祝居鲁士大帝时，挥霍了大量金钱购买荒谬的法国食物。他确实这么做了，但我认为称他为吸血鬼太刻薄了。这是一种隐喻。好吧，没问题。我的意思是，我认为你……
That's harsh. Well, he's suck. I mean, he lavished masters of money on ludicrous French food in celebrating Cyrus the Great. He did, but I think it's harsh to go from that to call him a blood sucker. It's a metaphor. Okay, fine. I mean, I think you're...
我不是说他真的是个吸血鬼。如果有任何亲国王的伊朗流亡者在听，我在此与汤姆划清界限。他确实……我的意思是，他确实掠夺了伊朗。嗯，他非常腐败。他非常腐败。他很软弱。他有很多宫殿。
I'm not saying he's literally a vampire. If there are any Shah-friendly, a Iranian exiles listening, I'm distancing myself from Tom here. He did. I mean, he did loot Iran. Well, he was very corrupt. He was very corrupt. He was weak. He had loads of palaces.
而且我认为他很愚蠢。但我不认为他是本世纪最糟糕的暴君之一。我的意思是，他有一支相当可怕的秘密警察。我的意思是，考虑到他们是一支可怕的秘密警察，说这话很疯狂，但他们并不像某些人那样可怕。关于可怕的错误，你认为他们与伊斯兰共和国的秘密警察相比如何？这在历史的其余部分非常罕见。我只想说，我不知道。
And he was foolish, I think. But I don't think he's one of the worst tyrants of the century. I mean, he had a pretty hideous secret police. I mean, this is a mad thing to say, given that they were a hideous secret police, but they weren't as hideous as some. On the hideous mistakes, how do you think they compare to the Islamic Republic's secret police? This is very rare for the rest of history. I'm just going to come out and say, I don't know.
好吧。嗯，我想这取决于你站在哪一边，可能吧。我想我更有可能最终站在伊斯兰共和国秘密警察的对立面。我绝对会。嗯，你绝对会，毫无疑问。无论如何，埃及人为国王举行了国葬。萨达特总统是首席哀悼者。
Okay. Well, I suppose it depends. Which side you're on, probably. I'd be more likely, I think, to end up on the wrong side of the Islamic Republic's secret police. I definitely would. Well, you definitely would, no question. Anyway, the Egyptians organised a state funeral for the Shah. President Sadat was the chief mourner.
吉米·卡特，你认为他去了吗？不，我不认为他去了。他当然没去。到这个时候，他已经在咒骂国王了。弗兰克·辛纳屈去了吗？没有，但我告诉你谁去了。他坐经济舱去的，这显示了他的诚意。节目的朋友，理查德·米尔豪斯，
Jimmy Carter, do you think he went? No, I don't think he did. Of course he didn't go. By this point, he's in his effing and blinding against the Shah. Does Frank Sinatra go? No, but I tell you who did go. He flew economy, and that shows his commitment. Friend of the show, Richard Milhow,
尼克松。他坐经济舱飞往开罗致悼词。你知道他是怎么评价国王的吗？他说，他是个真正的男人。不像谁？不像，不像吉米·卡特，显然。尼克松去参加居鲁士大帝的派对了？不，我不认为他去了。我愿意认为他的副总统斯皮罗·阿格纽去了，但我不能确定。我得查查。无论如何，尼克松说，国王是个真正的男人，吉米·卡特对国王的处理是美国历史上黑暗的一页。我的意思是，这对卡特来说真的很糟糕，不是吗？因为一方面，他让国王进来了，所有人质都被抓走了。而另一方面，他一点功劳也没得到。他输得一塌糊涂，没错。现在，实际上，到这个时候，卡特有更大的事情要担心了。
Nixon. He flew economy to Cairo to give the eulogy. And do you know what he said of the Shah? He said, he was a real man. Unlike who? Unlike, unlike Jimmy Carter, obviously. Had Nixon gone to the Cyrus Great Party? No, I don't think he did. I'd like to think that Spiro Agnew, his vice president, went, but I'm not certain. I'd have to check. Anyway, Nixon said, the Shah was a real man and Jimmy Carter's treatment of the shah is one of the black pages of American history. I mean, that's really poor for Carter, isn't it? Because on the one hand, he's let the shah in and all the hostages have been taken. And on the other hand, he doesn't get any credit for it at all. He's lost every way, exactly. Now, actually, by this point, Carter's got bigger things to worry
所以他没能点亮白宫的圣诞灯。这是一件事。因为，当然，人质还没有被释放。这种情况持续的时间越长，对旗帜的团结就越弱。人们对软弱的感知不断增强。这不仅仅是关于伊朗。我们谈到了通货膨胀，经济变得越来越糟。所以美联储，在新的货币主义老板保罗·沃尔克的领导下，
about. So he hasn't been able to turn on the White House Christmas lights. That's one thing. Because, of course, the hostages have not been released. And the longer this has gone on, the rallying around the flag has weakened. And the people, and the people, perception of weakness has built and built. And it's not just about Iran. We talked about the inflation, and this is, the economy has got worse and worse. So the Federal Reserve, under its new monetarist boss, Paul Volker,
他是过去50年左右经济史上一个非常重要的人物。他们提高了利率以抑制通货膨胀。所以利率在1980年春天达到近18%的峰值。真的，真的非常严厉。结果是美国经济在1980年1月陷入了深度衰退。在接下来的几个月里，仅制造业就损失了100万个工作岗位。这就是国内的情况。
a really important figure in economic history in the last 50 years or so. They've put up interest rates to squeeze inflation. So interest rates will peak at almost 18% in the spring of 1980. Really, really punishing. The result is the American economy. in January 1980 goes into a deep recession. A million jobs in manufacturing alone are lost in the next few months. And that's the picture at home.
国外的局势更糟。甚至在伊朗革命之前，卡特就因为太软弱而遭到抨击。所有关于共产主义崛起、美国倒退的言论。但现在看来，实际上正如人们所预测的那样，伊斯兰革命正在蔓延。所以在美国大使馆被占领两周后，伊斯兰激进分子占领了麦加的大清真寺，正如你所知，汤姆，那是伊斯兰教中比任何其他地方都更重要的地方，实际上。
The picture abroad is even worse. Carter was getting a hammering for being too weak even before the Iranian revolution. All this talk about, you know, communism in the ascendant America going backwards. But now it seems like actually just as people have predicted, the Islamic revolution is spreading. So two weeks after the American embassy seizure, Islamist militants seized the grand mosque in Mecca, and as you will know, Tom, that is the one place in Islam that matters more than any other, effectively.
那真的是麦加。在被沙特军队驱逐之前，战斗持续了两周。数百人丧生。来自德黑兰的霍梅尼说，这次占领是一次“假旗行动”。这是犯罪的美国帝国主义和国际犹太复国主义的作品。而且听起来很疯狂，很多人相信他们。所以在此之后，到处都有反美示威，
It's literally Mecca. There's two weeks of fighting before they're evicted by Saudi troops. Hundreds of people are killed. Khomeini from Tehran says, this occupation was a false flag operation. It was the work of criminal American imperialism and international Zionism. and as mad as it sounds, a lot of people believe them. So there are demonstrations against America after this,
从土耳其到印度尼西亚和菲律宾。在巴基斯坦的伊斯兰堡，在利比亚的的黎波里，暴徒实际上把美国大使馆烧成了平地。他们将其夷为平地。有一种感觉，这是前所未有的，穆斯林世界已经崛起，并且正在与美国进行战争。嗯，与“大撒旦”进行战争。
everywhere from Turkey to Indonesia and the Philippines. In Islamabad and Pakistan, in Tripoli, in Libya, mobs literally burn the U.S. Embassy to the ground. They raise it to the ground. There is a sort of sense, and this is unprecedented, that the Muslim world has risen up and is in, is in, a war against the United States. Well, against the Great Satan.
我的意思是，我认为那个短语真的火了。是的。我的意思是，《时代》杂志在这件事发生几天后宣布霍梅尼是其年度人物。《时代》杂志，当然经常代表美国中产阶级，说，你知道，他的革命比希特勒征服欧洲以来的任何政治事件都更重要。现在这对一些听众来说可能听起来言过其实，但这就是1970年的想法。而且实际上，当我们回顾过去40年左右时，他们一定错了吗？然后我要告诉你谁缺席了这次谈话，终于要加入聊天了，
I mean, I think that phrase is really taking fire. Yes. I mean, Time Magazine, a couple of days after this, announced that Khomeini was its man of the year. And Time Magazine, which speaks, of course, so often for kind of middle America, said, you know, his revolution matters more than any political event since Hitler's conquest of Europe. And now that may sound overblown to some listeners, but that was the thinking in 1970. And actually, were they necessarily wrong when we look at the last, you know, 40 years or so? And then I'll tell you who's been absent from this conversation finally about to enter the chat,
克里姆林宫。因为在1979年圣诞节，克里姆林宫的决策者们自己也对激进的伊斯兰教感到非常惊恐。当然，因为他们在苏联中亚的边界内有很多穆斯林。他们决定干预阿富汗，以支持他们在喀布尔的共产主义傀儡政权，对抗圣战者，即那些讽刺地已经被美国人资助的叛乱分子。吉米·卡特在戴维营。他正和女儿艾米看一部叫《黑神驹》的电影。
the Kremlin. Because on Christmas Day, 1979, the policymakers in the Kremlin are themselves very alarmed about radical Islam. Of course, because they have a lot of Muslims within the borders of the Soviet Union in Central Asia. And they decide they're going to intervene in Afghanistan to support their communist client regime in Kabul against the Majahadine, the insurgents who are already being funded, ironically, by the Americans. And Jimmy Carter is at Camp David. He's watching a film called The Black Stallion with his daughter, Amy.
当他接到电话时，苏联军队已经越过了阿姆河，即亚历山大大帝曾经越过的奥克苏斯河，进入了阿富汗。他想，天哪，不可能更糟了。几天后他告诉国会，我们现在正面临自第二次世界大战以来最大的和平威胁。就好像在他们所说的从中东延伸到中亚及更远地区的“危机新月”上，共产主义、激进伊斯兰教正在进军，而西方民主资本主义正处于困境。
When he gets a call, Soviet troops have crossed the Amudaria River, the Oxus, once crossed by Alexander the Great, and they've gone into Afghanistan. And he thinks, oh my God, like, it couldn't get worse. And he tells Congress a few days later, we are now facing the Great. threat to peace since the Second World War. It's as though all across this kind of what they call the crescent of crisis going through the Middle East into kind of Central Asia and beyond. Communism, radical Islam are on the march and Western democratic capitalism is embattled.
那么一个可怜的花生农场主该怎么办呢？对。所以现在美国人民有一种撤退和失败的真实感。卡特的支持率正在暴跌。而且他的许多顾问，别忘了，选举是在11月，现在只剩下几个月了。他的许多顾问都在想，如果我们现在不做点什么，我们就完了。他的幕僚长汉密尔顿·乔丹，我提到过他几次。他的回忆录里有一个故事。
So what's a poor peanut farmer to do? Right. So there's a real sense now among the American people of retreat and failure. Carter's approval ratings are tanking. and a lot of his advisors, don't forget, the election is in November, only months to go now. And a lot of his advisors are thinking, if we do not do something now, we are doomed. His chief of staff, Hamilton Jordan, I mentioned him a couple of times. There's a story in his memoirs.
有一天，他12岁的侄子对他说，为什么总统实际上什么都不做？他为什么什么都不做？汉密尔顿·乔丹对他说，嗯，做什么？这个孩子说，炸掉伊朗，把他们全部消灭。我在学校的很多朋友都说吉米·卡特没有胆量做任何事。你知道他们需要谁吗？是的。柯蒂斯·李梅将军。
One day, his nephew, who is 12 years old, said to him, why doesn't the president actually do anything? Why doesn't he do anything? And Hamilton Jordan said to him, well, like what? And this kid said, bomb their arm, wipe them all out. a lot of my friends at school say that Jimmy Carter doesn't have their guts to do anything. You know who they need? Yeah. General Curtis LeMay.
那个认为核战争是件好事的人。在一个乔治·华莱士在1976年当选总统，柯蒂斯·李梅作为竞选搭档的平行宇宙中，伊朗革命，事情会发生非常不同的转折，我想。但实际上，你知道吗？这些小屁孩的伙伴们错了。吉米·卡特确实有胆量做点什么。因为在1980年3月22日，卡特召集他的国家安全团队到戴维营，他说，好吧，是时候考虑一个非常激进的选择了。
The guy who thought nuclear war was a good thing. In an alternative universe where George Wallace had become president in 1976 with Curtis B. LeMay as his running mate. The Iranian Revolution, things would have taken a very different turn, I think. But actually, do you know what? This little brats, mates are wrong. Jimmy Carter does have. have the guts to do something. Because on the 22nd of March 1980, Carter summons his national security team to Camp David and he says, okay, fine, it's time to consider a really drastic option.
他转向参谋长联席会议主席，他的军事首长们现在揭开了美国历史上最大胆的赌博之一的计划，一个精英特种部队飞入伊朗中心，进入德黑兰营救人质的计划。这是一个令人难以置信的、令人瞠目结舌的大胆计划。但是汤姆，它会成功吗？嗯，你得等到下一集才能知道。悬念，我们有。如果你想听，嗯，你可以加入我们自己的精英特种部队，
And he turns to the head of the Joint Chiefs of Staff and his military chiefs now unveil the plan for one of the most daring gambols in American history, a plan for an elite special forces unit to fly into the heart of Iran to make their way into Tehran and to rescue the hostage. It's an unbelievably jaw-dropping the audacious plan. But Tom, will it work? Well, you'll have to wait until the next episode to find out. Cliff Hangers, we've got them. And if you want to hear, well, you can join our very own elite special forces unit,
“历史余味”俱乐部。通过这样做，你将能够立即听到最后一集。当然，你还会获得一系列额外的好处。你当然可以在therestishistory.com注册。多米尼克，谢谢你。谢谢大家的收听。再见。
the Restis History Club. And by doing that, you'll be able to hear that last episode right away. And of course, you'll get a whole host of extra benefits as well. And you can sign up, of course. at the rest is history.com. Dominic, thank you. Thank you, everyone for listening. Bye-bye.
再见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
Bye-bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。